[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur les chaînes parlementaires pour
suivre le discours de jean-luc mélenchon
à l'occasion de la convention de la
france insoumise qui se tient ce
week-end à clermont-ferrand un discours
de jean luc mélenchon prévu à 13 heures
dont le suivrons bien sûr en intégralité
sur notre antenne et pour l'analyser
trois invités sur ce plateau nicolas
prissette bonjour vous êtes journaliste
politique merci d'être là également sur
ce plateau le politologue stéphane rozès
bonjour je vous êtes également au
président de cap conseils analyses et
perspectives
et puis notre éditorialiste politique
ludovic fort ludovic et on va tout de
suite prendre la direction de clermont
ferrand où se tient cette convention de
la france insoumise retrouver à nathalie
gloire bonjour nathalie alors je le
disais nous sommes à un quart d'heure du
discours de jean luc mélenchon quels
sont les enjeux pour lui et pour son
mouvement la france insoumise oui
aurélienne c'est le tout début de cette
convention les militants sont en train
de s'installer comme vous pouvez le voir
juste derrière moi pour céder jour mille
six cents personnes sont attendues
et l'enjeu pourrait aujourd'hui et
d'organiser le mouvement pour qu'il dure
pour qu'il devienne un mouvement
permanent de la vie politique française
car depuis l'élection présidentielle la
france insoumise a besoin de trouver un
nouveau souffle
on rappelle que ce mouvement créé il ya
plus d'un an compte aujourd'hui plus de
550 mille inscrits mais n'a toujours pas
de chef d'exécutif officielle ni
d'instance de démocratie interne une
boîte à idées a donc été mise en place
depuis la mi août
elle a recueilli près de 4000
contribution et ce travail va permettre
de lancer durant ces deux jours trois
campagnes nationales
le reste concerne l'organisation du
mouvement qui se veut polycentrique
selon jean luc mélenchon une façon de
dire qu'il n'y aura toujours pas de chef
désigné à l'issue de ces deux jours de
convention car les insoumis ne cesse de
le répéter ici ils veulent absolument se
démarquer afin de ne pas devenir un
parti traditionnel merci beaucoup et
nathalie evian vous retrouvez tout au
long de cette édition spéciale avec
votre à votre micro à des réactions
politiques ludovic on a entendu à
l'instant à nathalie ernoult
expliquer quels étaient les enjeux de
cette convention pour la france
insoumise
est ce que cette convention pour jean
luc mélenchon c'est surtout un moyen de
redonner un peu d'élan la france 1,6
oui parce que on voit bien qu après un
début de quinquennat c'est réussir dans
l'opposition où la france a soumises a
parfois semblé être un peu la seule
opposition en tout cas audible notamment
à l'assemblée nationale eh bien c'est
plus difficile depuis depuis depuis la
rentrée et donc effectivement jean luc
mélenchon a besoin de retrouver ce que
ce que disait nathalie une sorte de
second souffle
peut-être parce qu'il ya déjà une sorte
de phénomène d'usure un finalement en
seulement quelques mois parce que pour
l'instant tous les efforts qu'a pu faire
jean luc mélenchon que ce soit dans la
rue ou à l'assemblée nationale pour
s'opposer à la politique d' emmanuel
macron bien tous ces efforts n'ont pas
porté leurs fruits il n'a pas réussi à
faire reculer le président de la
république et le gouvernement et donc ça
manque peut-être déjà un petit peu aussi
les limites de la stratégie d'opposition
radicale de jean-luc mélenchon à un
moment où on voit bien dans les sondages
que les français estiment qu'il est
encore trop tôt pour porter un jugement
définitif sur sur la politique du
président va revenir vous parlez les
données qu est-ce que nicolas prissette
aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon il doit
enrayer la spirale négative dans
laquelle se trouve son mouvement et dans
laquelle il se trouve
alors c'est vrai que il ya eu des
promesses de jean luc mélenchon qui
n'ont pas été tenues
on se souvient qu'il avait dit que un
million de personnes pourraient déferler
sur les champs-elysées contre la réforme
du code du travail mené par ordonnance
par le gouvernement d'edouard philippe
bon bien sûr on n'a pas vu un million de
personnes déferler sur les
champs-elysées et à constat un peu
d'échec de la part de jean luc mélenchon
qui a été formulée par lui-même ans il a
expliqué il a reconnu que emmanuel
macron avait gagné en quelque sorte la
première manche sur la réforme du droit
du travail alors aujourd'hui sont en jeu
c'est bien sûr de trouver évidemment un
second souffle sachant qu il n'est tout
de même pas en si mauvaise posture ce
jean luc mélenchon puisque le français
le crédite d'être le meilleur opposant
par le premier opposant à emmanuel
macron c'est quand même une place plutôt
enviable quand on sait la compétition
qui a pour l'occuper marine le pen est
bien allé derrière laurent wauquiez est
derrière aussi c'est jean luc mélenchon
qui aux yeux des français incarne
aujourd'hui celui qui est capable plus
de porter la contradiction
donc au président de la république et
fort de ceux de ce statut politique
acquis et bien on peut imaginer que lors
de son discours et au cours de cette
convention et bien jean luc mélenchon va
essayer de continuer de marquer son
territoire marqué son territoire à
gauche l'essayer peut-être d'aller
encore plus loin
et de poursuivre sa stratégie une
stratégie semble-t-il de rose de
rassemblement qu'il tente de faire avec
d'autres forces à gauche on verra si ça
marche en tout cas il est peut-être dans
un un moment moins bon qu'au moment des
présidentielles mais c'est pas si
mauvais pour lui on va regarder un
sondage un don vous parlais à l'instant
nicolas c'est un sondage au dos que ça
pour france info et le figaro vous le
voyez
parmi les personnalités suivantes le
meilleur opposant selon les personnes
interrogées à emmanuel macron et au
gouvernement c'est bien jean luc
mélenchon suivi 2 marine le pen de
laurent wauquiez et de benoît hamon
loin derrière ça c'est le point positif
pour le moment stéphane rozès c'est que
il a encore cette image de meilleur
opposant jean luc mélenchon oui nicolas
prissette l'a très bien dit c'est déjà
énorme
c'est déjà absolument énorme ce sondage
qu'ils apparaissent comme je dirais
l'oppositon meilleurs opposants
est ce qu'il peut être la meilleure
alternative
est-ce qu'il peut représenter
l'alternance c'est ça le sujet
maintenant pour lui pour les quatre ans
et quelques qui viennent parce qu'on va
le voir pendant discours ça a été très
bien dit ou six par jean luc fau qu'elle
au fond quelle quel bilan va tirer de
son échec
après effectivement à ce moment de
rentrer parce que au fond il s'est
trompé sur le sens de l'abstention
législatives y pensait qu'il pouvait
faire des abstentionnistes une force au
service un troisième tour social pi
s'est trompé ça veut dire que il a mal
analysé d'articulation d'un autre pays
entre la question sociale et la question
politique
il n'a pas pu effectivement quand il
reconnaît que au fond emmanuel makouri
passé sur la question des ordonnances
travail c'est que dans notre pays c'est
le politique qui conduit le social et la
verticalité politique permet à emmanuel
mâcon d'être dans cette situation de
surplomb d'avoir là
légitimité nécessaire et suffisante et
donc on va voir avec ludovic et nicholas
que nous allons entendre des leçons qui
leur a tiré en termes d'organisation
d'orientation idéologique pour tenir
pour rester sur sur le point de ce
sondage est d'avis qu'un on l'a vu
laurent wauquiez actuellement est en
troisième position sauf que leur vaut
qu'elle n'ait pas encore chef des
républicains est ce que les choses vont
changer à partir de dûmes de ce mois de
décembre quand il aura pris la tête
alors pour jean luc mélenchon pour
laurent wauquiez d'aider des semaines à
venir un vraisemblablement le premier
tour de l'élection pour la présidence
des républicains c'est le 10 décembre et
il est vraisemblable que laurent
wauquiez l'emportera dès le premier tour
on verra ce qui se passe ensuite dans
les jours et les semaines les semaines
qui suivent et se sont largement fait
globalement il y n'y tiges et pour jean
luc mélenchon parce qu'à la fois il
reste dans l'esprit des français le
meilleur opposant pour l'instant en tout
cas emmanuel macron en même temps sa
popularité est plutôt en baisse l'a en
revanche
et puis quand on regarde dans le détail
63% des personnes interrogées ont une
mauvaise image de jean luc mélenchon et
et quand on regarde un petit peu dans le
détail on voit que majoritairement des
catégories qui sont pourtant importante
pour lui le juju en images aujourd'hui
de façon plutôt négative
c'est le cas par exemple de 53 % des
jeunes de 54 % des ouvriers et de 61%
des français aux revenus les plus
modestes toutes ces catégories qui sont
censés être un peu le coeur de cible de
l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon donc
on voit bien qu'il est effectivement une
période un petit peu charnière où il a
beaucoup vécu finalement sur l'élan de
sa campagne présidentielle est
maintenant bien il ya un quinquennat à
tenir un au moins jusqu'aux prochaines
élections qui sont les élections
européennes mais que c'est dans un an et
demi encore comment on peut l'expliquer
nicolas prissette cette baisse cette
chute de popularité de nicolas mélange
de jean-luc mélenchon et y compris le
devis que le disais dans les catégories
qui sont porteuses pour lui normalement
c'est jean luc mélenchon
c'est vu peut-être trop trop beau et a
fixé des objectifs sans doute trop élevé
vouloir faire en sorte que le
gouvernement renonce à la réforme du
code du travail aux ordonnances c'était
un pari absolument impossible tous les
gouvernements qui arrive qui sont
qu'après une élection présidentielle qui
met en oeuvre leurs réformes
les passes toujours sans difficulté même
si celles ci ont pu être réputé comme
impopulaire à un moment ou à un autre
pendant la campagne ou pendant les
années qui ont précédé
souvenez vous par exemple en 1997 lionel
jospin fait la réforme de france télécom
qui avait suscité des semaines et des
mois de blocage
auparavant nicolas sarkozy met en place
le service public le maintien du service
public minimum dans les transports
juste après son élection bon c'était
aussi une mesure dont on expliqué
auparavant qu'elle serait très
compliquée à mettre en oeuvre compte
tenu des hostilités syndicale dans la
rue se passe exactement la même chose
avec emmanuel macron l'arrêt cette
réforme du code du travail a été prévu a
été dans le programme il n'y a peut-être
pas une majorité de français pour
l'approuver les yeux fermés mais en tout
cas il n'y a pas une majorité de
français pour s'y opposer
on est dans la légitimité qui vient
juste après l'élection présidentielle et
donc le paris jean luc mélenchon de
faire en sorte que cette réforme ne se
passe pas c'était un peu un pari à pari
très osé un peu insensé
ludovic c'est l'échec de ces
manifestations contre cette réforme du
code du travail qui a décrédibilisé jean
luc mélenchon en partie d'ailleurs de ce
point de vue là il a sans doute eu
raison de dire que sur les ordonnances
emmanuel macron avait marqué le point
c'était c'était son expression puisque
ce sondage montre que finalement les
français ont le même sentiment puisque
79 % des personnes interrogées estiment
que la mobilisation contre contre les
ordonnances voulu notamment par jean-luc
mélenchon que ces mobilisations ont été
un échec
après ce qui est vrai c'est là une
raison de le reconnaître ou est ce que
c'est vrai que des chèques saleh
affaibli
bah disons que un petit peu des deux
c'est à dire qu on ya vu un petit coup
de blues
peut-être de ne pas avoir réussi
effectivement à faire plier emmanuel
macron et en même temps c'est une preuve
de lucidité quand presque 80% finalement
des personnes interrogées estiment que
de toute façon ça a été un échec
c'est un peu compliqué de
de défendre le contraire après là où
nicolas tout à fait raison c'est
qu'effectivement jean luc mélenchon a
sans doute eu les yeux un peu plus gros
que le ventre et notamment parce qu'il a
voulu incarner et il a échoué ans a
aussi une sorte d'opposition un peu
globale où il prétendait incarner à la
fois l'opposition au parlement
l'opposition dans la rue et puis volonté
de prendre une forme d'hégémonie à
gauche il n'y est pas parvenu
et donc c'est aussi l'échec de cette
stratégie qui se lit peut être dans dans
ce dans ce sondage on va continuer à en
parler mais on va tout de suite
reprendre la direction de clermont
ferrand je vous rappelle qu'on attend le
discours de jean luc mélenchon dans 5
minutes maintenant
et on va retrouver nathalie gloire avec
manuel bompard le directeur des
campagnes de la france insoumise oui je
suis avec manuel bompard alors est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire aujourd'hui
quelles sont les enjeux de cette
convention est ce que la france aura
soumises a besoin de retrouver un second
souffle
ce gros souffle non parce qu'on n'est
pas essoufflé mais il s'agit de
déterminer des nouveaux objectifs pour
la période qui s'ouvre est notamment on
va révéler aujourd'hui trois campagnes
nationales du mouvement sur des
propositions de son programme pour
répondre aux problèmes concrets que
rencontrent les français c'est les
campagnes qu'on annoncera dans l'après
midi et sur lequel l'ensemble du
mouvement va se mettre en route au
travail pour convaincre les citoyens de
la pertinence de ses propositions pour
montrer que au delà d'être une force
d'opposition la france a soumise est la
première force d'opposition aujourd'hui
n'a vocation aussi être une force
d'alternative pour exercer le pouvoir
demain
alors aujourd'hui un sondage est sorti
il annonce une baisse de la popularité
de jean luc mélenchon qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
écoutez les sondages vous savez il ya
des hauts et des bas c'est pas très
intéressant pour nous le même sondage
dit que jean luc mélenchon est identifié
comme le premier opposant politique
emmanuel macron donc au delà du sondage
et aller retour de terrain quand on est
au contact de la population une
population qui souffre beaucoup
aujourd'hui des mauvais coups du
gouvernement et elles comptent sur nous
cette population je crois pour l'aider
pour être entre aaron on lui propose
d'être un outil à sa disposition
voilà ce qu'on en pense qu'on en pense
et qu'il faut continuer le travail de
mobilisation faire échec à la politique
gouvernementale et préparer une
alternative parce que il faudra bientôt
exercer le pouvoir pour répondre aux
défis qui sont devant les français
l'inégalité de la richesse la transition
écologique l'impasse démocratique dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui le risque de
guerre partout dans le monde il ya des
grandes questions qui sont posées aux
français la france a soumis à la
prétention de pouvoir apporter des
réponses sur ces sujets alors il n'y a
pas de chef à la tête de la france a
soumis ce militant jean luc mélenchon
est ce que les sites ce deux jours il va
être désigné officiellement chef du
parti
non je rigole un chien il est président
du groupe parlementaire à l'assemblée
nationale
à ce titre là il participe bien
évidemment de l'animation nationale du
mouvement
mais l'objectif c'est de garder au
mouvement une structure de décision que
ça a une structure collective et qui
s'appuie sur plusieurs espaces qui
existent dont le groupe parlementaire
fait partie de ces différents espaces
mais à l'issue de cette convention il y
aura pas de chef du mouvement il y aura
une assemblée représentative qui réunira
des membres de ces différents espaces et
des insoumis tirés au sort et qui sera
finalement l'instance de coordination
nationale du mouvement
merci manuel bompard d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions sur les chaînes
parlementaires
merci beaucoup et nathalie est tout à
l'heure manuel bompard parlais à
l'instant de ce qui finalement est un
paradoxe ans nicolas prissette paradoxe
de cette ce mouvement-là franz insoumise
qui est incarné par jean luc mélenchon
et qui n'a officiellement pas de chef
oui alors bien sûr ça ne trompe
absolument personne puisque jean luc
mélenchon ça serait difficile de lui
contester le leadership de ce mouvement
la france insoumise même regardé après
les initiatives des personnalités de la
france insoumise ont émergé à
l'assemblée nationale des visages que
les français ne connaissais pas qui ont
pris la parole dans les médias qui ont
même sur occupé les médias pendant un
certain temps cet été mais qui n'ont
jamais contesté leur chef c'est à dire
qu' on aurait pu lui reprocher en
interne à la france info me devais
d'avoir perdu la présidentielle après
leur avoir promis de les mener jusqu'à
la victoire
c'est pas du tout ce qui s'est passé là
les gic
et jean luc mélenchon n'est absolument
pas remise en cause en tout cas dans ce
qu'on entend de la part des députés de
ce camp et c'est évidemment le contraste
absolu avec le front national ou là vous
avez des déchirements des gens qui
partent comme filippo non à la france
insoumise c'est pas ça qui se passe
c'est l'unité une unité derrière ce chef
ce leader même s'il n'a pas le statut
officiel bien c'est bien mélenchon qui
dirige la france a soumis selon stéphane
rozès c'est un chef sans l'être
officiellement mais c'est un chef
incontesté de ce mouvement j'en lis un
parallélisme dans les modalités
d'organisation et d'incarnation des
trois forces qui ont existé durant cette
présidentielle
emmanuel macron avec la république en
marche
marine le pen y compris avec le front
national avec sa crise que nicolas
prissette a indiqué est ce que l'on
entend de ce que serait la france
insoumise au fond il ya un césar et puis
il ya en bas du réticulaire c'est à dire
des réseaux et l'horizontalité le césar
est là pour tenir ensemble des
différences sensibilité qui existe des
facto dans le pays comme dans les
formations politiques pour la france est
soumise
il ya deux types dax il ya d'un côté les
protestataires et de l'autre ceux qui
veulent être dans les institutions qui
correspond à un autre axe
ce qui met en avant la tradition sociale
dans la tradition proue de miss qui
remonte au 19e siècle et ceux qui
mettent en avant la dimension
républicaine politique dans la tradition
je dirais socialiste et celui qui tient
ça c'est jean luc mélenchon on l'a vu
d'ailleurs récemment lorsque une députée
communautariste que certains suspectent
de complaisance islamo-gauchiste a
commencé à mettre en péril la france a
soumises tellement alliés en dehors de
ce qui fait la tradition républicaine en
france très vite on a vu les numéros 2
sortir du bois contre 7 députés et
ensuite jean luc mélenchon dire une deux
choses pour remettre de l'ordre dans la
maison on va le voir sur d'autres
dossiers
là où il ya un paradoxe peut être
concernant jean luc mélenchon c'est
qu'effectivement
et fait un peu figure de domme
providentiel au sein de la france
insoumise alors qu'il conteste
finalement la monarchie républicaine la
vème république qui veut passer à la
6ème république
il a npd pendant ma campagne pour la
révocabilité des élus là où il ya une
différence avec le front national et la
république en marche et qu'en revanche
aussi bien marine le pen que emmanuel
macron assume tout à fait effectivement
cet aspect de la vème république qui qui
ressemble parfois à une forme de
monarchie républicaine et c'est là qu'il
ya peut-être effectivement tête une
contradiction quand même chez jean luc
mélenchon et la france insoumise
c'est-à-dire d'assumer pour le parti un
fonctionnement qu'il conteste pour le
pays mais aussi une grande habileté
politique de sa part à s'être tenus à
l'écart de toutes les polémiques qui ont
séquencé
depuis l'élection présidentielle et qui
ont touché la france insoumise un
compensa raquel garrido ces polémiques
danièle obono on vient d'en parler le
logement social d alexis corbière et
c'est jean luc mélenchon aurait pu être
touché par ces affaires il aurait pu en
payer finalement le prix en étant bien
accuser d'être responsables d'être d'un
parti voilà avec des pratiques
contestables et bien ça n'a pas été le
cas parce qu'il s'est toujours mais en
retrait de ces affaires-là il a laissé
ses députés ces élus s'en occuper et
c'est d'être étaient eux mêmes et puis
il s'était épargné finalement bien
d'être touchée d'être pour défendre
danièle obono à ressurgir sur jean luc
mélenchon est sûre le parti pendant sa
récente baisse de popularité on peut
peut-être quand même voir un peu les
faits quand même de ces polémiques de
ces de ces controverses et et même dans
le fait que la france insoumise a été
moins audible ces dernières semaines
qu'elle ne l'avait été
cet été parce que des gens comme alexis
corbière qui est député ici et qui fait
partie des porte-voix de la france
insoumise et bien ces deux dernières
semaines cet effet un petit peu discret
en raison de effectivement de la
polémique sur le
logements hlm dont il bénéficie avec
avec sa campagne
raquel raquel garrido et c'est pas
impossible quand même que tout ça est
impactée un petit peu quand même l'image
de la france insoumise et et même de
jean luc mélenchon qui pourtant plaide
un contre le voile à un certain nombre
de davantage dans dont peuvent
bénéficier les classes favorisées et
donc alors il ya eu ces polémiques sur
sur les logements encore une fois dont
bénéficiaient certains responsables de
la france et insoumise et puis les
polémiques concernant danièle obono qui
ont pu gêner quand même une partie de
l'électorat effectivement qui qui à
cette conception de la de la république
et de la laïcité chevillées au corps
danièle obono en a remis une couche si
je puis dire elle défend les stages en
non mixité raciale organisée par le
syndicat d'enseignants sud éducation 93
est ce que jean luc mélenchon va pouvoir
continuer longtemps à ne rien dire sur
ces sujets alors officiellement on l'a
entendu protéger un danièle obono il a
eu des propos pour non pas pour
l'excuser mais pour remettre dans le
contexte et puis redire son soutien et
s'est distingué des groupes on va dire
qu'ils ont pu avoir des propos
antisémites ou racistes près desquels
daniel bonneau avait semblé avoir voilà
une certaine complaisance
donc je tends luc mélenchon a essayé de
faire la part des choses
officiellement dernier le bono bien fait
toujours partie bien sûr de ses protégés
mais à l'intérieur de la france sont
soumises les propos quand ils se
libèrent sont beaucoup plus sévères que
ce que tient jean luc mélenchon
officiellement et les critiques sont
beaucoup plus acerbes
donc on comprend bien que ce type de
situation ne pourra pas perdurer
longtemps sans que lui même jean luc
mélenchon soit un jour touché par
éclabousser par le temps qu'ils
fonctionnent tant que les équilibres
fonctionne ça va effectivement mais
jean-luc mélenchon est un politique sa
république a et il sait que le npa
d'olivier besancenot absolument disparu
de la scène stéphanoise est question de
comptes s'interroge jean-luc mélenchon
vient toujours de prendre la parole à
clermont ferrand va l'écouter tout de
suite en change dans notre rituel
politique et ça a valeur d'un signal
nous n'avons pas voulu que ce qui se
passera ici
temps dedans je ne sais quelle
signification vers la conclusion que
j'apporterai à ce que nous allons faire
et puis c'est aussi une manière de
marquer pour nous le passage officiel
cette fois-ci incontestable au collectif
les dix-sept visage que vous avez appris
à aimer dans le groupe parlementaire et
tant d'autres qui sont dans l'animation
du mouvement la france insoumise
dorénavant sans que plus personne
puisque le constater nous sommes d'une
équipe diverse
nous sommes une équipe de femmes et
d'hommes capables de gouverner ce pays
et c'est à cela que nous aspirons
et c'est la démonstration que nous
voulons faire à travers le déroulement
de ces deux journées de travail beaucoup
de codes vont être cassée je sais très
bien que ce que nous on est déroutant
puisque nous n'allons pas élire des
chefs nous n'en n'avons pas besoin et
nous n'avons pas l'intention
d'introduire ici les terrifiantes luttes
de personnes qui ont détruit toutes les
autres organisations politiques
nous n'allons plus non plus tranché je
ne sais quel débat idéologique que
d'aucuns nous aurait assigné à trancher
aujourd'hui avec l'espoir que nous nous
déchirons et j'ai noté que ceux là même
qui me traitait de dictateurs naguère
dans renavand me demande d'exercer je ne
sais quelle police politique de la
pensée dans le groupe parlementaire est
ailleurs il n'y en aura pas la force de
la france insoumis c'est qu'elle est un
mouvement
elle n'est pas à partie et n'a donc pas
besoin d'une homogénéité des pensées
elle a besoin d'une homogénéité de
l'action et c'est pourquoi elle est
toute entière tournée vers l'action
il n'y aura pas de police de la pensée
ici personne n'est obligé de répéter ce
que je dis ni ce que dit un autre pour
autant chacun est appelé à faire preuve
de la plus grande cohésion et discipline
dans l'action parce que c'est elle qui
nous permet d'économiser nos forces et
d'être vraiment à point d'appui pour les
plus faibles qui comptent sur nous voilà
la mort à l'essentiel de ce que nous
allons entreprendre il existe autour de
nous une ambiance chaleureuse
jamais le peuple ne nous tourne le dos
jamais les braves gens n'hésitent qui a
proposé de venir boire un café qui à
toute heure du jour et de la nuit de
faire des photos grand dieu des photos
des scènes fille s'appelle bon cette
ambiance chaleureuse temps demain à tant
de visages tant de beaux regards tournés
vers nous mais en même temps cette
ambiance cinq mois ininterrompue de
dénigrement qui ont blessé 6
profondément quelques-uns d'entre nous
qui ont une vie entière honnête et loyal
a déployé devant les autres avec bien
sûr des moments qui ont été durs de
pauvreté
pour quelques-uns d'entre nous cinq mois
de dénigrement et des fois la cadence de
deux buzz par semaine qui nous ont
frappés individuellement mais aussi nos
familles traîner au pilori médiatique
qui n'en peuvent déjà plus d'avoir à
nous supporter ce qui est dommage
ce n'est pas tant que nous ayons à subir
tous là bas on va reprendre cyrano de
bergerac
nous ne renonçons pas à l'honneur d'être
une cible mais pour autant cela souvent
a fait perdre de vue ce qui à nos yeux
est l'essentiel je ne parlerai que pour
ce travail qui manque l'outil je
pourrais citer d'autres amis si petit
dans ses luttes qui dans son assemblée
j'ai en face de moi
danielle simonnet des mois de combat
pour elle
pour dénoncer la farce collaborateurs de
dèche et combien d'eau je me tourne ici
là je vois que des visages de
combattants ici sabrina ali maintenant
ces combats pour la santé ailleurs enfin
bref je vais finir par offensé si jeune
homme car il y en aura tant que j'aurai
oublié
et puis nous dans ce travail qui pour ma
part mme englouti en tant que président
du groupe parlementaire comme je
regrette que le peuple ne puisse pas
savoir savoir que nous avons fait plus
3540 intervention que nous avons fait
plus de deux mille amendements que nous
avons présenté plus de 500 propositions
qui lui permettrait de savoir à quel
point oui on peut gouverner autrement
non la france n'est pas voué aux riches
et nous n'avons pas besoin d'eux
nous n'avons pas besoin d'eux pour faire
le bien et organiser notre société
autrement sur les bases de la fraternité
quoi qu'il en soit ne nous laissons pas
happer n'y parlait ni par l'esprit de
vengeance nil par les rancoeurs il nous
faut mes amis restés toujours le coeur
grand ouvert et la main tendue
ne tombons pas dans l'ambiance de
violence verbale qui rhein dorénavant et
qui blesse si profondément l'esprit
public opposant les uns aux autres en
fonction de leur religion de leur
couleur de peau de leur étiquette
politique que sais-je encore
nous sommes le mouvement de la paix
civile
nous sommes le mouvement de la raison
nous sommes le mouvement de
l'argumentation pas de l'avis du père à
sion needle invectives comme il est loin
ce temps où l'on disait de moi parce que
je prétendais par les crues et dru
que je serai excessif et agressive
depuis vous avez été régaler de sinik
rien finit en petits enfants qui
attendaient le père noël et caetera et
caetera et caetera et je ne cite pas
évidemment l'ignoble monsieur valls et
ses aboiements permanent ne vous laissez
pas ap mais protéger
ayez chacun aliot chacun au coeur la
protection le développement dans tout ce
pour quoi elle a été créée de la france
insoumise de ses 4000 good action
nous sommes encore bien fragile mes amis
et nombreux sont ceux qui aimeraient
nous voir chuter
mais souvenez-vous à chaque instant que
c'est du monde entier qu on vous regarde
que font-ils quand ils organisés est-ce
qu'ils ont des succès comment aj styles
et tout le monde dans bien des pays
tous ceux qui se sentaient abandonnés
tout d'un coup on a un point d'appui en
france là où vibre pour le monde entier
parfois à tort l'idée que la révolution
est logé pour toujours alors ayant ceci
à l'esprit nous avancerons sur la même
orientation qui nous réunit depuis le
début fédérer le peuple pas de
tambouille pas de combines pas
d'alliance secondaire ou tertiaire qui
nous font nous retrouver dans des
situations insupportables
ne croyez pas que je vous dis ça avec
plaisir
on me dit vous êtes seul qu'est-ce que
j'y peux
d'abord nous tue pas si seul que ça nous
étions 7 millions la dernière fois il ya
pire solitude mais que voulez-vous que
je vous dise quand nous sommes à
l'assemblée nationale ou sur le terrain
évidemment à l'assemblée nationale nous
sommes la main dans la main avec les
députés communistes sur le terrain avec
des militants de toute étiquette mais si
nous regardons la scène institutionnels
qu'est ce qu'on me demande à la fin
dois-je et pourtant nous avons
des gestes nous avons dit nous sommes
prêt s'il le faut à parler même avec les
socialistes à condition qu'ils se disent
d'opposition mais voilà qu'ils votent
sur la confiance 5 votre la confiance 3
votre contrat avec nous et tous leurs
seins s'abstient qu'est ce qu'une
opposition qui s'abstient à propos du
gouvernement auquel il s'oppose
ça n'existe pas et quand bien même ils
votent contre la politique de ce
gouvernement comme ce fut le cas pour la
loi de finances vous à retrouver un
gouvernement trois jours après autrement
dit braves gens chaque fois que vous en
élyséen
il peut y avoir tromperie sur la
marchandise
c'est la raison pour laquelle il n'est
de bonne opposition qu'opposition
populaire la nôtre et nos députés
on nous demande si nous sommes bien les
premiers opposants mais on ne savait pas
qu'il y avait un concours et d'ailleurs
on n'a pas l'impression que ça se
précipitent pour concourir si bien que
comme dit l'autre à à vaincre sans péril
on triomphe sans gloire
ces corneilles l'autre c'est dans le cid
bon nous ne sommes pas candidats d'un
improbable podium au présent nous le
sommes ça se sait ça se voit c'est sans
concession c'est honnête c'est argumenté
mais ce n'est pas cela que nous sommes
candidats nous sommes candidats à être
les meilleurs les plus utiles les
citoyens et les citoyennes les plus
engagés au service de l'intérêt général
c'est ça que nous voulons être c'est ça
notre fierté et notre honneur parce que
voyez-vous la conscience est une chose
comme elle est nécessaire comme il doit
se nourrir d'arguments et de raison mais
il y a la conscience qui débouche sur
l'action et c'est l'action qui fédère
c'est pourquoi avant toute chose nous
sommes
le mouvement des luttes du peuple le
mouvement des luttes du peuple
cela signifie que nous nous sentons
meilleur en tant qu'individu plus grands
différente de ce que nous serions sans
cela dès lors que nous unissons aux
autres par l'action pour le bien général
et c'est à ce moment là que nous sommes
pleinement un être humain car nous nous
préoccupons non seulement de nous aider
notre et de nos proches
mais de tous les autres et nous nous
sentons enfin à part entière membres de
l'humanité mes amis ici nous allons nous
préparer à une chose accompagner aider
le peuple français
face au choc qui vont maintenant déferlé
sur lui au les françaises et les
français savaient bien il en était déjà
en voyant tout ce qui se dégradent
autour d'eux en voyant la difficulté
quotidienne à vivre mais voilà qu'il va
leur passer dessus les conséquences du
projet de loi de finances qui vient
d'être adoptée à l'assemblée nationale
16 milliards de rétractation du
périmètre de l'état des milliards
consacrés exclusivement à compenser les
cadeaux qui vont être faits aux riches
par la suppression de l'impôt sur la
fortune et par la création d'une taxe
qui les dispense de payer au-delà de 30%
des bénéfices qu'ils auront réalisé
cette pluie d'argent va en direction
d'une classe sociale qui pour l'instant
s'est comporté en pur parasites sans
rien apporter au bien-être de la nation
londres 10 et bien c'est la théorie du
ruissellement voyez-vous honorant leur
argent comme si on leur avait volée et
avec ça ils vont investir dans
l'économie crée des emplois bla bla bla
bla bla bla vous connaissez la suite de
la récitation
je fais comme si on pouvait le croire un
instant et alors
on ne peut qu observer que les faits
disent le contraire
le capitalisme français dans les années
70-80 consacré 30 % des bénéfices à
rémunérer les actionnaires
aujourd'hui c'est 80 % autrement dit
quoi qu'on leur donne quelle que soit la
quantité
ils prennent toujours plus et cet argent
vous veut renvoyer pas dans l'économie
réelle
il part dans la bulle financière cette
bulle qui gonfle chi gong qui depuis
2008 la dernière crise a déjà tellement
augmenté que les niveaux de
capitalisation boursière ont rattrapé
ceux de 2008 et que la prochaine
explosion est à l'ordre du jour parce
que le capitalisme est incapable de se
corriger
incapable de se maîtriser parce qu'il
repose entièrement sur la conjugaison
des intérêts particuliers sans jamais se
soucier de l'intérêt général parce qu'il
pense que l'intérêt général va résulter
mécaniquement de l'addition des intérêts
particuliers les productivistes ne
peuvent rien faire d'autre que de
produire encore et toujours n'importe
quoi dans n'importe quelles conditions
sans tenir aucun compte ni du saccage
humain ni du saccage de la nature c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous sommes
fondamentalement une force
anticapitaliste pour la raison que nous
sommes fondamentalement une force
humaniste c'est à dire celles qui se
préoccupent de l'harmonie de la vie des
êtres humains entre eux et avec la
nature
toute chose à jamais incompréhensible
pour le capital de notre époque
sur ces 16 milliards de rétractation de
l'état 10 milliards sont destinés à
compenser les cadeaux aux riches et 6
milliards sont de la réduction pure et
simple du service public
mes amis vous allez voir ce que vous
allez voir
hélas vous le verrez dans vos communes
où les dotations de fonctionnement vont
diminuer ce n'est pas étonnant ce
pouvoir qui applique la feuille de route
de la commission européenne est hostile
à la commune à l'existant des communes
au profit d'entités massive qui pompe et
puise tout le tissu humain social
politique d agglo des supers agglo que
sais-je encore dont personne ne sait où
sont les gens qui les composent
ni qui les a désignés là ni ce qu'ils
font or je vous demande de vous en
souvenir notamment pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas eu le temps de la prendre
la commune est la base de la liberté des
français depuis des siècles
c'est là que s'est construit la
conscience collective et la liberté
dès le xiiie siècle dans ma commune
marseille
le conseil des gens disaient métier volo
blesse au xiiie siècle les idées
révolutionnaires ont pu s'exprimer dans
la commune par la commune avec la
commune la commune est l'instance à
laquelle nous ne renoncerons jamais et
pour laquelle je vous appelle à une
lutte acharnée
consciente permanente pour la protéger
et la défendre comme le département
d'ailleurs après quoi le choc qui va
être reçue tous ces services publics qui
vont être supprimés
et vous savez comme moi gens de bien que
les premiers services qu'on supprime
quand il manque c'est toujours les mêmes
la culture qui pourtant transformé un
hobby l'être humain le sport tu lui
permet de se rendre maître de lui-même
et ainsi de suite
morceau par morceau cet appauvrissement
de la vie
que vont devenir les pitchous mme qui
n'auront pas été à la bibliothèque parce
qu'elle est fermée que vont devenir ceux
qui n'auront pas pu aller au club de
sport
que vont devenir ceux qui n'auront pas
été transportés et qui font qu'au xxième
siècle vous avez des jeunes à 20 km de
la capitale qui ne sont jamais sortis de
leur commune comme autrefois ce qui ne
sortait jamais de leur village où est
cette grande période où l'on brasse m
brasse et où il y avait des maisons des
jeunes et de la culture
pourquoi tout cela at il disparu alors
que la patrie est plus riche qu'elle ne
l'a jamais été
pourquoi cet appauvrissement de la vie
comment pouvons-nous le comprend nous ne
le comprenons pas nous ne l'admettons
pas nous inverserons sitôt élu le moment
venu toute cette tendance et après quoi
regardez voici
l'école saccagés avec cette réforme des
collèges qui fait que les enseignants
les plus allants ceux qui ne renoncent
jamais finissent par se demander qu'est
ce qu'on attend au juste 2 quand on leur
présente des groupes de classe dont ils
ne savent ni ce qui a été appris l'année
précédente
nuit ce qu'ils vont apprendre l'année
d'après oui quand l'école est saccagée
alors on touche le coeur même de notre
identité commune le coeur même de ce
qu'est la république le coeur même de
l'idée que demain peut être meilleur si
nous sommes nous-mêmes meilleur par le
savoir la culture et les sciences
et bien après cela vous aurez la loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale
on ne vous l'a peut-être pas dit mais
ils ont retiré de là dedans quatre
milliards et demi alors que le système
de soins du pays et déjà exemple ne
tient plus que par le dévouement de ceux
qui se trouve dedans et ce dévouement
n'est pas sans limite comme en atteste
le nombre des suicides que l'on constate
parmi les personnels de santé comme dans
tous les autres secteurs de la fonction
publique où l'on a sans cesse exiger
davantage sans donner jamais les moyens
de faire mieux dans tout ce service où
des gens commencent la journée de
travail en sachant qu'en toute hypothèse
il ne la finir au pas contents de même
parce qu'ils n'ont pas bien pu faire
tout ce pourquoi ils sont là exécuter
parfaitement leur métier poser les bons
gestes professionnels à vous autres les
puissants vous ne savez pas ce que c'est
que d'aimer son travail
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est que de
vouloir qu'il soit bien fait vous ne
savez pas ce que c'est que d'être
content quand on a tiré d'affaires un
jeune parce qu'on est dans un club de
prévention et qu'on est un professionnel
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est
quand vous avez tiré quelqu'un de la
maladie parce que vous l'aviez bien
soigné vous le savez pas ce que c'est
que d'avoir dans sa classe un gamin une
gamine dont on pensait que socialement
et bien les conditions qui pesait sur
lui sont trop lourdes
pour qu'ils relèvent la tête et pourtant
il la relève et ses beaux yeux clac de
lumière parce qu'il sait voilà nous ce
que nous savons de la vie à tous ceux
qui sont dans le secteur de la santé je
sais que vous allez passer une très
mauvaise année je n'ai pas de conseils
ni de leçon à donner mais une chose est
certaine
seule la lutte paie parce qu'ils
n'entendent rien d'autre le troisième
choc que va recevoir le pays
c'est quand il va s'apercevoir que tout
ce qui était en l'état d'urgence qui
était un état exceptionnel sera
dorénavant passer dans la loi ordinaire
et jusqu'à présent l'état d'urgence il a
surtout servi à réprimer des militants
syndicalistes et des militants
écologistes
davantage que des terroristes c'est pour
toi
nous devons être ce mouvement des
combattants et quand je dis combattants
bien sûr le mot peut paraître guerrier
mais c'est celui qui désigne le mieux la
condition dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons j'ai ici en face de moi jérôme
schmitt qui est par ailleurs un
responsable syndical
et je veux lui rendre hommage comme à
tous les syndicalistes qui sont dans
cette salle métal aux enseignants
électriciens gaziers cheminots ce
mouvement à le vaud c'est votre
politique qui s'exprime ici et que nous
portons la défense des services publics
la du nickel de travail
alors qu rue saluer tous pour souligner
ce courage et le mettre en exergue pour
que vous abaissiez bien tous ati nous
devant nos libertés je veux saluer la
présence dans notre salle de philippe
chrisman ouvrier du bâtiment
condamné à cent soixante quinze mille
euros 17000 euros damende 18 mois de
suite pour avoir jeter des confettis sur
le bâtiment de la fédération nationale
du bâtiment du tnp m
lève toi en tant que voix camarades
elle tombe en effet condamné
une fois qu il
yverdon
et pourquoi
je
white qui avec ses confettis à la
fédération du bâtiment parce que ce
jour-là le syndicat organisé une
manifestation en défense des malheureux
qui part du fait de la pénibilité du
travail dans cette branche
professionnelle particulière cumule un
mort sur deux de ceux qui périssent
chaque année dans l'indifférence des
puissants qui n'ont jamais un mot pour
eux 5 165 morts par an je ne cesserai de
le dire d'une réunion à l'autre
565 personnes pam des hommes arrachés à
l'affection des leurs et au bien-être de
toute la société du fait des conditions
d'organisation du travail et dans le
bâtiment c'est particulièrement dur
voilà pourquoi quand vous voyez un
exemple comme celui ci vous vous sentez
fier d'appartenir à l'accorte humaines
capables de produire de tels individus
et en même temps vous sentez est gonflé
dans votre coeur la rage contre ceux qui
veulent les humilier leur faire baisser
la tête savez-vous ce qu'ils ont trouvé
juste avant les vacances de noël ils y
ont saisi son compte
voilà mes amis et après on vous
appellera la gentillesse et la docilité
à baisser les yeux
il ya vous montrer responsables et bien
moi demain j'irai jeter des confettis
aussi s'il le faut et vous autres avec
moi elle peut-être même d'autres choses
les faits en face de françois hollande
je réclame l'amnistié sociale pour les
travailleurs les syndicalistes
[Applaudissements]
non
combattant
parce que c'est notre fonction notre
rôle nous avons choisi librement de
l'être soyons éclaireur comme nous
l'avons été tant de fois sur tant de
sujets d'antan de circonstance aux
éclaireurs c'est un mot qui parfois
coûte cher il en est qui jette la
lumière sur des zones d'eau où l'on
préférerait ne rien voir
ainsi sont les lanceurs d'alert haut
comme nous avons été fiers que céline
boussier accepte d'être candidate de la
france insoumise aux élections
législatives alors qu'elle était déjà
sous le coup d'approché en diffamation
que lui faut ceux sur qui elle a jeté la
lumière un bleu femmes quatre ans de
combat perdant son emploi à perdre en
tout mais tenant bon et quand je lui dis
ça va elle dit je regrette rien et pour
la première fois pour la première fois
dans notre pays une femme une lanceuse
d' alerte est passé au tribunal et elle
a été relaxée
je sais me soir l'occasion de féliciter
toute l'équipe qui a mené cette lutte
avec elle dont elle portait évidemment
l'essentiel du poids mais amie
marie-laure darrigade et combien
d'autres parfois par dessus la maladie
menant la lutte mais surtout ce que je
veux dire à cet instant c'est que nous
n'oublions pas la cause pour laquelle
tout cela était fait c'est la défense et
la protection de la dignité de nos
petits qui sont malades d'autisme et
nous n'acceptons pas qu'ils ne se
fassent toujours rien pour prendre en
charge la totalité des enfants autistes
de ce pays pour les soigner leur
permettent d'avancer et de trouver leur
place dans la vie éclaireurs des amis
nous l'avons aidé tant de fois par nos
choix dit vous vous souvenez quand je
suis venu avec ma salade de quinoa
alors on avait bien préparé notre coup
un bon il s'agissait d'être déclencheur
alors me voilà avec la salade de quinoa
en train d'expliquer il est temps de
passer aux protéines végétales plutôt
qu'aux protéines carnet à tous les
rustres se sont esclaffés haha mélenchon
le kinois et comprenant sa presque du
quinoa m'enfin bon peu importe
et les voilà trépidante bavant de joie à
l'idée de peut-être pas revenir quelques
secondes à me ridiculiser moi et ma
salade mais finalement le thème a fait
son chemin
pas grâce à nous mais par la
mobilisation constante de toutes sortes
de gens dans ce pays et notamment des
vegan et qui ont permis de bien faire la
démonstration à laquelle nous voulions
arriver
vous ne pouvez pas continuer à sacrifier
chaque année 65 milliards d'animaux et
1000 milliards de poissons pour nourrir
la population humaine comme vous la
nourrice est actuellement et au rythme
auquel vous êtes
elle devrait s'accroître cette
production de 75%
cela n'est pas possible il faut passer
aux protéines végétales en plus grand
nombre dans la nourriture et pour cela
il avait raison ceux qui lancent l
alerte alors il faut changer
l'agriculture pour qu'elle procède
autrement pour qu'elles produisent
autrement il y a un lien très intime
entre le capitalisme fou des productions
aberrante et pour terminer une
maltraitance de masse des animaux qui
doivent être sacrifiés en telle quantité
qu'ils sont traités comme des choses à
bas les fermes des mille vaches abattues
ces persécutions inutiles qui
flétrissent l'humanité par son
indifférence devant les êtres sensibles
il faut changer l'agriculture la nature
est le premier enjeu de la période
politique dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons
vous avez tous vu que d'ici quelques
semaines il faudra trancher sur la
question du glyphosate autrefois dans
les réunions de l'opposition populaire
on ne parlait pas de chimie mais
maintenant il faut bien en parler si
vous trouvez dans 53% des cours d'eau
53% des cours d'eau dans 100% des urines
humaines des traces de ce glyphosate
sous sa forme soi-disant décomposer le
lan pas plus dangereux que le glyphosate
lui même et que les divers thèmes
suivants qui sont mis avec ce produit
sur la nature et jusqu'à une date
récente
on en passe et sur les blés avant la
récolte pour l'instant on se contente
d'en mettre avant eh bien vous ne pouvez
plus regarder ça et regarder ailleurs
l'organisme liée à l'organisme mondiale
de la santé qui fait des recherches sur
le cancer dit que ce produit est très
probablement cancérigène
ce que nous savons au contact d'autres
professionnels de la santé c'est que les
dégâts qu'ils occasionnent ont peut-être
déjà à voir avec les conditions dans
lesquelles naissent nos enfants
aujourd'hui et l'état dans lequel il se
trouve trop souvent il faut interdire le
glyphosate pas seulement le reporter de
trois ans l'autorisation ou de cinq ans
comme l'ont demandé le ps et la droite
au parlement européen pour ensuite dans
trois ans ou dans 5 ans recommencer la
discussion c'est maintenant qu'il faut
l'interdire et pour l'interdire il faut
cultiver autrement il faut pratiquer
autrement il faut une autre agriculture
il faut plus de monde
il faut que l'on accepte de payer ce que
la production agricole vont
alors qu'aujourd'hui on l'a sous payent
pour des produits de mauvaise qualité
bien sûr l'appel le plus pressant ne
croyez pas que celui là ne soit pas prêt
sans empoisonner des générations de gens
c'est un appel pressant que d'y mettre
un terme
surtout quand on est on connaît les
conséquences comme je voulais dit il ya
un instant sur la génération
mais évidemment l'appel le plus pressant
concerne le climat vous avez quinze
mille experts qui disent ce qu'on disait
avant avant de même à leur suite dans
nos réunions il dit cette fois ci la
cote dallaire est en train d'être
franchie je vous avais expliqué que
l'accord de la coop 21 c'était un
réchauffement climatique prévu annoncés
de 2% mais qu'en réalité les documents
qu'ils avaient envoyées chaque pays
montrait que chaque pays au total
control additionner avait une politique
qui conduisait à 3% 3 % par moins trois
degrés c'est la fin des haricots les
amis c'est la faim tout court du monde
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
alors on peut continuer à faire comme si
on n'avait pas vu qu'on ne sait pas et
ensuite se dire que les catastrophes
on trouvera le moyen de les régler on
trouvera le moyen de les régler comment
je vous prie si c'est avec le
capitalisme c'est avec la méthode chacun
pour soi apprenez à nager si c'est avec
les méthodes qui sont les nôtres
alors c'est tous ensemble il faut se
préparer sérieusement à faire face tous
ensemble mais en même temps il faut
arrêter la pente
eh bien je vais vous dire au prix d'un
paradoxe ce quelque chose qui pour nous
est très important et sur quoi j'ai
beaucoup consulté avant de vous en
parler à cet instant voyez-vous en
france grande nation ce qui bloque ce
qui sait qu'on ne se donne pas le mal de
chercher comment organiser la transition
énergétique notamment parce que c'était
évidemment usage du carbone et des
énergies carbonées qui provoque l'effet
de serre qui débloque le climat ce qui
fait qu'en france on estime qu' on a le
temps on verra c'est le nucléaire tant
qu'il ya le nucléaire ils se sentent
exemptes est du devoir de faire autre
chose c'est une des raisons
supplémentaires
nous amenons dans le débat pour dire il
faut arrêter le nucléaire nous
remercions ceux qui croyant bien faire
longtemps salessy dit si bien
nous leurs jetons pas la pierre mais il
faut arrêter c'est dangereux dans ce
mandat
ce mandat présidentiel 19 réacteurs
arrivent au bout de l'existence qui
était prévu pour eux de 40 ans le grand
carénage coûtera entre 100 150 milliards
pour refaire le carénage de ses
centrales nucléaires la même somme nous
permettrait de passer aux nouvelles
énergies aux énergies renouvelables
l'objectif de 100% d'énergies
renouvelables est un objectif immédiat
il faut s'y mettre maintenant si l'on va
continuer l'accueil des menteurs et des
tricheurs qui viennent nous annoncer
qu'on va réduire dans le mix énergétique
à 50 % ils vous disent pas si pendant ce
temps l'énergie aie le monde pas plus
haut à dire ça n'a pas besoin de
davantage équipe à tous il bavarde as au
lieu d'agir si bien que la france pays
qui a pour la partie métropolitaine neil
km de côtes n'a pas une seule éolienne
installée en mer pas une et je me
souviens de françois hollande faisant un
discours extrêmement satisfait de lui
comme d'habitude et qui annonçait une
production en mégawatts qu'il
envisageait d'installer sans se rendre
compte que c'est les chiffres qu'il
était en train d'annoncer était
inférieur à ce qui avait été prévu
c'est vous dire le degré d'impréparation
des élites de ce pays à la compréhension
des enjeux
quand alstom a été vendu à la cge
nous avons alerté immédiatement que nous
étions en train de perdre un savoir
faire qui permet d'installer des
éoliennes et tout ce qui va avec
le premier parc d'éoliennes installées
au large des états unis d'amérique a été
réalisé par une entreprise française
alstom alstom a été vendu à cge le reste
à une entreprise allemande et espagnole
et maintenant qu'est ce que nous
apprenons que la cge va peut-être être
en faillite
autrement dit nous serons les premières
victimes des coupes et d'ailleurs ils
ont commencé puisqu'il commence par
fermer une entreprise qui est à grenoble
où se fabriquent les turbines on va dire
en général qui équipe
écoutez bien ça le 25 % du parc mondial
c'est un savoir faire extraordinaire
quand vous rencontrez un ouvrier de
cette entreprise vous lui dites ça fait
combien de temps que tu travailles là
est le gars il vous répond s'entend
parce que ça fait cent ans que cette
boîte est là et que le savoir s'est
transférée de l'un à l'autre
en plus des savoirs fondamentaux qu'il
faut accueillir il n'y a que les têtes
d'oeuf technocratique
les financiers qu'on l'a fourré partout
dans les bureaux et qui prennent la
décision à la place des ingénieurs y a
que pour croire qu'il suffit de claquer
des doigts et de mettre de l'argent sur
la table pour que surgisse les savoir
faire
ce n'est pas vrai si cette entreprise
est perdu alors c'est tout ça qui sera
perdue et c'est pourquoi nous défendons
l'industrie nous la défendons nous
voulons la promouvoir
parce qu'il s'agit de produire autre
chose et autrement et que nous voulons
pouvoir le faire nous même en étant
indépendant en étant autonome avec les
moyens dont dispose ce pays
pour les financer
le nucléaire doit s'interrompre mes amis
autrefois c'étaient les verts qui
portait ce combat il avait raison contre
beaucoup d'entre nous est maintenant
c'est à nous de relever le flambeau
je sais que vous avez classé parmi les
premiers thème de préoccupation cette
question j'ai vu et bien j'ai à vous
dire ceci n'y allait pas par demi mesure
non ce n'est pas un sujet à côté non ce
n'est pas un sujet marginal qui ne
concernerait que les bobos tout le monde
mourait en même temps si tout ça ce
détraqué se dérègle quelle que soit sa
classe sociale
quel que soit son chèque quelques places
à religion quel que soit ce genre la
question de la dangerosité du nucléaire
est une question d'intérêt général alors
c'est à vous de relever ce flambeau et
si vous êtes à la recherche d'une action
tout à l'heure dans vos ateliers
je me permets de faire une proposition
organiser une votation citoyenne
le jour de l'anniversaire de la
catastrophe de fukushima
parce que ce jour là peut-être qu'ils
vont tous réfléchir et se rendre compte
du danger qui pèse sur nous
bon le 12 décembre si tout le monde dans
la rue
manifestation contre le sommet qui m'a
finances ils repeignent envers la
finance qui manquent pas de souffle
le système bancaire mondial à financer
373 milliards d'euros dans l'industrie
du charbon
eh bien nous expliquer maintenant
comment ils vont faire autrement
alors on attend avec beaucoup de
curiosité et puis d'ailleurs les grandes
banques
ils ne sont jamais en retard d'un
mauvais coup fraude fiscale et évasion
fiscales et autres activités indigne
elle aide les pollueurs à ne pas payer
d'impôts total 5 milliards de bénéfices
et 0 euros d'impôts l'a dit quoi bon
tout ça ça doit nous amener un point
fondamental fondamental de politique
d'accord c'est de la philo d'accord mais
un point fondamental
l'humanité est qu'elle le veuille ou non
une et indivisible
dans son environnement une et
indivisible hommes femmes quel que soit
votre couleur
quel que soit votre genre alors
réfléchissons aussi nous autres nous
autres qui croyons que le peuple est
l'acteur de l'histoire nous savons que
la première condition pour qu'il le
devienne c'est qu'ils puissent s'unir
dans un projet politique menée au nom de
l'intérêt général pour qu'ils puissent
s'unir pour qu'ils perçoivent qu'il y a
un intérêt général
il faut nous dans notre bataille
politique nous opposer à tout ce qui les
divise et veut leur faire croire qu'ils
n'appartiennent pas à la même communauté
humaine parce que leur religion
parce que leur couleur de peau parce que
ils sont hommes où ils sont femme
d'alors
nous sommes ses militants de l'unité du
genre humain et de l'universalisme
ce qui commence par une première chose
[Applaudissements]
l'égalité en droits des êtres humains
n'est rien aussi longtemps que le
patriarcat continuera à dominer la scène
du dodo de nous voir à d'illustrés tous
autant qu'on ait une rude et terrible
leçon
la mise à jour des violences que
subissent les femmes interpelle toute la
société et en particulier chaque homme
je veux dire
chaque être humain masculin comment
avons nous pu supporter tout ça comment
avons nous pu ne pas le voir ou ne pas
avoir envie de le savoir
et quelle part chacun at il pu prendre
or je ne dis pas à la violence mais à
tout ce qui entoure culturellement les
violences sexuelles
dès lors il ne faut pas se payer de mots
nous ne voudrions pas que tout cela
débouche sur je ne sais quel grand
discours très officielle suivie de 0
moyens concrets pour faire face à la
situation des milliers de plaintes ont
été déposées
elle doit pouvoir être reçus et traités
et non pas compter sur la lenteur pour
étouffer des moyens considérables
doivent être déployés pour pouvoir
entendre pas seulement écouter entendre
ce qui se dit et le traduire en mesures
concrètes
enfin plus personne doit pouvoir penser
qu'il est exemple du risque c'est
pourquoi
si je peux donner un conseil à cette
convention
je lui suggérerais de créer à
l'intérieur du mouvement à la france
insoumise une cellule d'écouté d' alerte
et de répression s'il le faut
une amitié une indivisible comme nous
avons été meurtri par la découverte d'un
marché aux esclaves en libye nous autres
français nous sommes directement
concernés car c'est un de nos présidents
qui a dévasté ce pays et conduit au
chaos qui permet maintenant ce genre de
trafic
nous sommes concernés responsable nous
ne pouvons pas nous dire ignorants de la
question qui est traitée à cet égard car
dans le royaume et dans l' empire
l'esclavagé a existé et bien des ports
français des grandes villes françaises
ont construit leur fortune sur ce
commerce abominable il ne suffit pas de
regretter pour ceux du passé il faut
s'intéresser au présent en pensant en
pensant mes amis que ce n'est pas une
affaire libyenne
quand on parle d' esclavage c est une
blessure qui ne s'est pas fermé
parmi les milliers et milliers de nos
compatriotes des caraïbes et des
différents pays où l'on à pratiquer l
esclavage
déjà à l'époque les intéressants et les
importants avec diarra ne vous pouvez
pas abolir ça vous allait ruiner les
colonies et c'est alors qu'a jailli la
grande parole de robespierre dont je
suis avec beaucoup ici fier d'être un
des héritiers périssent les colonies
plutôt qu'un principe
enfin il faut pour que cette humanité
que ce peuple arrive à se constituer
comme acteur initiés de l'histoire que
la religion ne viennent pas en politique
divisée tous ceux qui ont vocation à
s'unir que cela soit bien entendu c'est
la position du livret thématique de
notre programme pas de religion en
politique tu as de religion en politique
alors
nous ne voulons pas elle nous le disons
clairement pour que nul ne puisse en
ignorer nous ne voulons pas que la
laïcité soit transformé en prétexte pour
mener une guerre de religion contre une
religion l'islam la laïcité protège le
droit des musulmans de croire elle
protège le droit des juifs le droit des
catholiques le droit des protestants et
elle protège le droit pour les 60% de
français de n'avoir aucune religion
si cela leur convient
alors nous sommes en droit d'exiger du
pouvoir la plus grande clarté et pas
seulement des admonestations ou des
doigts pour montrer des gens
nous demandons que la république soit
fondamentalement et jusqu'au bout laïque
le président de la république n'a pas à
être le curé du pape en tant que
chanoine de latran
on ne peut pas dire un jour nous ne
voulons pas de religion en politique et
le lendemain à l'hfr furet du pape
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que soit
maintenu le concordat nous ne pouvons
pas accepter que les populations soient
privés là et en guyane et ailleurs des
bénéfices de la loi de 1905
alors si vous voulez parler de laïcité
commencer par balayer devant votre porte
avant de venir ici nous chercher de
pouillé noise
ah je vous préviens vous autres qui nous
entendent et de loin pas vous ici vous
savez il n'y a pas le choix ou bien il y
aura un pays pour tous ou bien il y aura
un pays pour personne
nous sommes un mouvement de la paix
civile de la fraternité
nous sommes le mouvement qui proclame
l'universalité de la condition humaine
nous sommes le mouvement qui s'inspire
de ces pauvres paroles que j'ai lu à
champagné dans la haute-saône où je me
trouvais j'ouvre ici un ami qui était le
lendemain il y avait vous savez les
meetings de l'hologramme je ne vous dira
que c'était pas une semaine fameuse pour
moi et pour nous tous eh bien j'ai fait
une halte à champagne et pascal
champagney c'est le premier village en
france où des gens ont été informés
qu'ils avaient des esclavages et quand
on leur explique et des listes au
possible et noir cela n'existe pas alors
le gall heures via mais si mais si ça
existe de ne voir je vais vous montrer
leur montre la peinture et il y avait
dessus base d'hazard comment il est noir
il a honoré notre seigneur qu'est ce que
vous dites qu'au fond les morts pas
question est donc pensé à cela
j'avais voulu le 4 février honorer la
première abolition de l'esclavagé et
bien que vivant nous et pour toujours en
pensant au pire le goût du meilleur
alors
voilà nous ne reconnaissons aucune
guerre de religion nous ne faisons pas
la guerre au catholicisme
nous faisons la guerre au cléricalisme
nous ne faisons pas la guerre à l'islam
nous nous battons contre l'islam
politique en toute circonstance et en
pleine fraternité avec la quasi-totalité
des musulmans voilà rien de plus rien de
mois était déjà assez
il n'y a qu'une seule communauté
naturelle la communauté humaine
politique la république et elle ne peut
être la république que si elle est
laïque alors j'en viens à cet épisode
sur lequel naturellement nous allons
nous attarder pas aujourd'hui mais
comment pouvez-vous nous faire tous ces
grands discours sur la laïcité ensuite
alors même que le congrès du parlement a
voté le contraire nous ramener par la
porte de service
un drapeau qui parait-il représente
toute l'europe mais qui a une
signification religieuse qui n'est
contesté par personne
et d'abord par celui qui l'a inventé si
vous voulez mettre 28 étoiles mais télé
et nous applaudirons mais ne lui
demandez pas d'adopter un symbole qui
est un symbole religieux car demain
l'europe doit être à tous ces enfants
quel que soit leur religion et même
s'ils n'ont pas grand dieu
je vous dis ça parce que l'europe va mal
et que c'est pas le moment de rajouter
des éléments d'éparpillement jeudi
qu'elle va mal quand je pense au peuple
quand je pense aux gens nous sommes dans
une pente d'éparpillement un
éparpillement profite qu elle vous avez
vu déjà comment les frontières bougent
ça a été le break site mais on voit
ailleurs les frontières import continuer
de bouger on me parle que celle de prix
mais massa mais sa fin
depuis qu'il ya le break site il ya le
problème de la frontière entre l'irlande
du nord et l'irlande du sud il y a le
problème de l'ecosse qui veut son
indépendance elle pour rester en europe
chacun a des raisons et puis maintenant
voici qu'apparaissent des batailles
indépendantistes comme celle qui a
récemment déchiré la catalogne
alors d'où vient cet éparpillement at il
une cause est la folie des êtres humains
non c'est toujours la même raison qui
est à l'oeuvre partout
celle qui divise déjà dans les peuples
c'est que cette politique fait pour
l'irish pour l'argent détruit la société
c'est ce que jacques généreux après la
dissociété la dynamique du capitalisme
financiarisé de notre époque on pose
tout à tout le monde
chaque personne à l'autre ont détruit le
code du travail ont détruit tous les
codes de manière à ce que se réalise le
miracle qu'ils attendent de l'individu
isolé qui le gère par lui-même et
d'après des normes rationnelle paraît-il
ses choix sas a conduit à l'opposition
de chacun contre tous à la destruction
tous les services publics à la
destruction de tous les services sociaux
et à la fin la nation reste une coquille
vide
si bien qu'elle apparaît à beaucoup de
ceux qui la composent comme une camisole
de force parce qu'ils se disent si je
n'étais pas là si j'étais ailleurs
peut-être que je m'en sortirai peut-être
que mes enfants s'en sortir et la cause
des nationalismes de notre époque et
dans la misère qui a été répandu par la
politique qui a été appliqué par l'union
européenne
c'est elle qu'il faut arrêter ça va être
difficile parce qu'une fois de plus ils
vont vouloir nous enfermer dans une
discussion pauvres est ce que vous
voulez sortir de l'euro comme si la
france dans sa grandeur et sa force
était pas capable de changer le statut
de la banque centrale européenne est de
faire de cette monnaie autre chose
est-ce que vous allez quitter l'union
comme si nous serions incapables nous
d'en produire une autre d'union
européenne s'il le faut le moment venu
avec ceux avec ceux qui voudront en
faire un espace de vie commune et pas
avec ceux qui veulent en faire un enclos
pour le capital nous avons tous les
moyens nous sommes un grand pays une
grande nation
personne ne nous donnera d'ordre ni
cette fois-ci ni jamais chaque fois
qu'il s'agira de revenir sur les
conquêtes que notre peuple a accumulé au
prix du sang et des larmes qui fait que
nous sommes cette grande nation
instruite soigner protégés que nous
avons été tout ce temps oui c'est de ça
dont il est question
pas de théories fumeuses de construction
géopolitique abstraite il est question
de la vie alors sa comédie continue le
mensonge continue le président de la
république a fait deux interminables
discours plus long que les miens il
évoque 18 fois la souveraineté
européenne et se garde bien une seule
fois de dire en quoi il consiste car
pour new republic a pour nous héritier
de la grande révolution de 89 la seule
souveraineté que nous connaissons c'est
la souveraineté du peuple et quand nous
avons fait campagne ça s'appelait la
france a soumis le peuple souverain
c'est ça le scandale qu'avait le peuple
souverain
s'il y a une idée qui nous distingue de
tous les autres courants c'est bien
celle-là le peuple souverain à travers
les institutions qui rendent possible
cette souveraineté et lorsque les
institutions ne rentrent pas possible
cette souveraineté alors ce sont des
institutions et demi ne venez pas nous
dire
le parlement européen est une forme de
la démocratie du peuple européen
non ce n'est pas vrai 70% des décisions
qu'il prend note aucune conséquence
concrète il ne peut pas discuter du
budget autrement que pour l'approuver ou
le repousser il n'a jamais l'initiative
des lois
ce n'est pas un parlement au sens
traditionnel du terme c'est à dire une
expression de la souveraineté populaire
et dès lors je dis la comédie continue
vous avez vu comment zorro en personne à
régler le problème des travailleurs
détachés regardé par ici ne regardez pas
la voilà donc on a raccourci la durée
pendant laquelle un travailleur
pourraient être détachés et ben pas de
bol c'est pas ça qu'on demandait parce
qu'ils ont raccourci à une durée plus
longue que la durée réelle c'est pas mal
ça c'est l'europe ça c'est l'europe
la carabistouilles embrouille l'enfumage
et il revient il est plus content de lui
et nous on lui dit mais c'était pas ça
le sujet mon gars
le sujet c'était où ils payent leur
cotisation sociale est bien avec ton
histoire il continue à les payer dans le
pays d'origine
par conséquent il n'y a rien de changé
c'est de la concurrence déloyale
là où vous avez un petit patron qui
prend un employé et qui le paye sa
sécurité sociale et bien si celui d'à
côté prend 1 travailleurs détachés qui
paye pas la sécurité sociale
alors ya concurrence déloyale vous voyez
je le prends du point de vue du petit
patron mais je peux en dire autant de
l'ouvrier car à penser l'ouvrier
français s'ils voient que sa sécurité
sociale va être ni té par ce système des
travailleurs du thé chez vous vous
rappelez quand j'ai dit oh tous crié
oies blanches sont ils venus xénophobe
c'est pas clair ben si c'est
parfaitement clair nous défendons la
sécurité sociale de notre pays nous
défendons l'égalité des droits des
travailleurs quels que soient leur
nationalité à être soignés sérieusement
et les inventions bizarres du chef de
l'état
ne servent strictement à rien pour
éclairer le débat parce que je n'avais
pas speedy je vous fais juste une
parenthèse parce que vraiment ça me
saoule tellement voilà qui dit ah bah
oui mais continueront à payer les
cotisations marche dit-il
moi je propose 10 macron qu'il continue
à payer les cotisations du pays mais ça
ira une caisse qui permettra aux autres
pays de se développer est ce que c'est
que ce truc
de quoi il parle naturellement rien de
tout ça ne sera mais parle pour parler
pour vous donnez l'impression que ça
continue à rouler alors que la paire est
arrêté c'est terminé le président macron
a avalisé le fait qu'il ya des
travailleurs détachés et qui ne payent
pas leurs cotisations sociales en france
à bas la décision qui a été prise et
après ça vous les avez vus ils sont
allés au sommet social papa musique
le sommet social de göteborg c'est sympa
waouh
alors déjà il ya un problème il ya pas
un allemand c'est la première économie
du continent mais sont pas là pourquoi
faisons pas de gouvernement a oui
pourquoi zone non pas parce que c'est la
crise ah oui quel genre de crise quel
genre de crise à votre avis la même que
ce qui détruit le reste de l'europe
voilà quelle crise ou si madame merkel a
fait un score aussi bas
et si l'extrême droite a pu se
développer en prenant prétexte de
l'immigration c'est que par dans un pays
où il ya 13 millions de pauvres
eh ben le terrain est préparé pour que
l'extrême droite 10 ne te laisse pas
volé de ton pain par semis qui arrivent
de l'extérieur parce que c'est toujours
comme ça qu'ils ont fait la racine de la
crise politique allemande
elle est dans la politique du
gouvernement allemand qui va imposer à
tout le reste de l'europe est la
deuxième cause c'est une fois de plus
les combines entre les partis de droite
et la social démocratie qui ensemble ont
étouffé toute joie de protestation
menacé tout le monde
injurier montrées du doigt qui n'étaient
pas d'accord avec eux tête enfouie en
irréalistes ou un déprimé comme moi
voilà voilà ce qu'a été le débat
politique
nous méritons mieux l'europe l'idée
européenne celle de la fraternité des
peuples méritent mieux
donc dans ce sommet social ils ont
adopté un socle de droit commun sauf que
là tu adores empire la bouche
sinon ça marche pas avant il y avait
qu'une pauvre charte mais la peau sharp
comptait plus de droits que le socle
autrement dit la grande avancée de la
dernière réunion c'est d'avoir beaucoup
reculé voilà ce que c'est une nouvelle
union il manque la puissance économique
la plus importante et où on adopte un
test est en recul par rapport au
précédent et c'est ça qu'on vient vous
vendre comme un grand progrès et la
marque d'un intérêt particulier pour le
social ces gens là ne s'intéresse à rien
d'autre qu'au fric il faut se le dire
une bonne fois pour toute ils n'ont pas
fait l'europe des peuples n'ont pas fait
l'europe des salariés iso fait l'europe
du fric et pour eux ça va bien la
prochaine élection européenne va être un
référendum sur la question européenne
ah ça va pas être facile de convaincre
les gens parce que les gens ils doha ça
sert à rien salut au revoir on t'aime
bien mélanger aux mauvais la prochaine
fois et il va falloir convaincre il faut
sortir du carcan
il faut briser les chaînes il faut
sortir des traités budgétaire européen
qu'on préparait est signée sarkozy est
ensuite hollande parce que c'est ça qui
pousse le continent entier à la misère
je pèse mes mots cailleux artisans l'on
vient
lully progrès ni propos c'est l'europe
de la défense
vous vouliez faire l'europe de la paix
et ils veulent préparer l'europe de la
défense
une europe de la défense complètement
inclus dans l'otan une europe qui montre
du doigt la russie comme un ennemi alors
que c'est un partenaire quand bien même
nous n'aimerions pas son gouvernement
mais c'est pas le seul qu'on aime pas
sur terre et en particulier même dans
l'union européenne comme par exemple le
gouvernement de monsieur urban hongrie
où le gouvernement polonais composé de
réactionnaire les plus noires qu'on
connaisse
voilà il est donc temps de tourner la
page
c'est ça que nous ferons car il y aura
une liste l'europe
insoumise aux élections européennes et
s'il y en a
il aura une transnationale l'europe à
souilhe avec podemos avec les amis grecs
avec de blanco avec trois amis deux
camarades
surtout le volant et s'est retrouvé sur
la tranche sociale
alors
elle disposera qu'il ya un plan à
mais qu'il est inutile de croire que si
on nous dit nous nous rentrerions à la
maison car il y a à plat et il ya plan p
et si vous ne voulez pas dupe là vous
n'aurez rien d'autre que le plan b
donc nous avons discuté raisonnablement
avec des gens déterminés comme nous que
de nous faire le numéro cruel et violent
que vous avez fait à la grèce on vous
prétendiez tout réparer et au bout du
martyr qui a commencé en 2010
la grèce est dans une situation pire
qu'elle n'était à l'époque ce qui montre
que leurs remèdes ne valent rien que
c'était juste des parasites et des tic
qui sont tombées sur la grèce
est ce que vous imaginez qu'il ya huit
milliards qui ont été prélevés sur la
grèce que nous étions censés aider est
bon nous l'avons tellement bien aidé que
lui ont fait les poches de 8 milliards
et nous les français nous exigeons de
notre gouvernement qu'il rende l'argent
qui a été pris aux grecs en tant qu
intérêts
avant cela les amis et camarades pour
certains d'entre vous précautions
oratoires ne savait pas si c'est les
amis ou les camarades certains d'entre
vous
avant cela il y aura des élections
nous sommes des démocrates des
républicains n'attendront pas les
élections et ne les avons pas attendu
pour mener la lutte
aujourd'hui les groupes d'action de la
france insoumise sont partout partout
sur tous les terrains
sur toutes les luttes il a près le même
ce qu'est l'auto organisation some
l'opposition populaire c'est-à-dire
l'opposition du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple et nous devons apprendre
à être efficace et pas seulement
déclamatoire des gens qui nous donnent
des conseils il y en a plein des gens
qui nous disent comment il faut faire
mieux que ce que nous avons déjà fait il
y en a plein
ceux qui voudraient nous ramener à la
case départ on les comprend où on
retrouverait les bonnes vieilles petite
baston à terme pour savoir qui c'est qui
va être le chef le sous-chef le
trésorier déchets fécaux pas dit non
cela n'aura pas lieu
le mouvement la france a soumises va
rester un mouvement pas partie je suis
membre d'un parti
vous ne m'avez jamais entendu faire de
la publicité pour lui ou essayez de vous
récupérer au compte du parti dont je
suis adhérent eh bien je demande que
tout le monde ça se traîne à la même
discipline et que chacun pense à tous
les autres au respect qui est dû à la
pensée du camarade et de l'ami car s'il
n'ya pas ici de police de la pensée
il y à une exigence de communautés de
fraternité de respect pour les autres il
faut qu'il faut parler jusqu'au point où
on se sent investie du destin de tous il
va y avoir de nouvelles élections mes
amis des élections partielles
nous attendons avec intérêt la suite de
ce que nous avons lu dans le canard
enchaîné
car le canard enchaîné nous le lisons il
comporte toutes sortes de choses
désagréables pour nous chaque semaine
nous avons appris à les contourner
avec le sourire pas toujours mais on
essaye ouais c'est comme les caricatures
et moi j'ai rien dit après tout moi
aussi j'étais caricaturer parce que vous
rappelez j'avais dit c'est la rue qui
nous a libérés des nazis aussi tome sont
tous tombés dessus en disant qu'ils nous
traitent de nazi jamais fait ça mais une
demi-heure après c'était plus ça le
sujet le sujet c'était la rue a fait les
nazis
ah ah ah ah les petits enfants enfin
match ne recommence pas passer avant
comme faire des histoires
en attendant j'étais en caricature avec
un brassard ffi que j'aurais eu de
l'honneur à porter en train de tendre
une femme la résistance
ce n'était pas ça le peuple en
résistance ce n'était pas assez violents
le peuple en résistance et celui qui a
aidé à libérer la patrie de l'ombre aux
nazis et qui les a frappés durement
encore et encore et encore nous nous
sommes libérés nous mêmes avec l'appui
des alliés mais nous nous sommes libérés
nous mêmes
quelle est l'histoire de france et
personne n'a le droit de revenir sur le
fait que c'est le peuple et la coeur de
l'histoire
bon il y aura des partiels on a lu dans
le canard quoi vous avez vu là le détour
qu'est ce qu'on a lu dans le canard qu'
il y avait 100 candidats la république
en marche qui ont reçu des factures sous
facturés il ne savait pas et on va pas
les montrer du doigt alors les factures
ont été remises aux prix du marché et du
coup comme c'était au prix du marché
il déborde du plafond des dépenses
autorisées sans ça fait 22 ans que la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
dans ce domaine est constant quand tu
dépasse le plafond et battait plus les
autres fois en plus tu était inéligible
maintenant jurisprudence a un peu levé
le pied tpu élus n'étaient pas
inéligible par conséquent on doit
s'attendre à ce qu'il y a un nombre
d'élections partielles plus important
que ce qu'on a connu dans le passé
eh bien nous serons là
partout sauf exception avec les
candidates et les candidats qui étaient
déjà là la dernière fois j'espère que
dans cette circonstance particulière
d'aucuns voudront bien remisé pour
quelques jours les arguments de hargne
qu'ils peuvent avoir contre une car dans
la dernière élection après que j'ai
entendu beaucoup protesté contre le
gâchis qui résulterait de notre attitude
le résultat était le suivant dans
quarante cinq circonscriptions
nous avons été incapables de franchir le
premier tour à cause de la concurrence
souvent se situe en cinq ou six points
par pouce à coût 6 points 5 e 6 fois en
dessous de nous j'espère que chacun fera
preuve de bon sens en attendant et quoi
qu'il arrive nous serons candidats
partout mes amis
vous avez compris deux visions du monde
s'affrontent l'intérêt du président
macron et qu'il est parfaitement clair
sur ses intentions
il mène une charge incroyable violence
tout en même temps au point de suffoquer
et c'est fait pour ça les oppositions
n'ont pas le temps de se constituer et
nous venons de subir un revers
il paraît que si je le dis et delà je
démoralise non je le dis parce qu'on est
démoralisé dans certains secteurs de la
société
parce que cette bataille a été conduite
en dépit du bon sens et je n'ai pas peur
de le dire et je le répète la division
syndicale nous a nui d'une manière
incroyable dans la bataille haute à ceux
qui en sont responsables
passeuse ans qui ont été les victimes et
par dessus le marché
le cadre de la séparation entre les
syndicats et la politique est absurde
surtout au nom d'un texte sur plus de
100 ans et qui dit exactement le
contraire de ce qu'on lui fait dire
aujourd'hui il faut absolument par
rapport aux batailles qui s'annoncent
que ce soit sur le plan social où que ce
soit dans les batailles écologique que
la convergence se fassent chacun dans
son rôle chacun dans son identité
chacun dans ses responsabilités devant
ses mandants mais que la convergence
face nous avons besoin de plates formes
de résistance populaire qui rassemble
tous ceux qui sont prêts à se battre
quelle que soit l'étiquette qu laquelle
ils sont prêts à se battre parce que
c'est ça qui va rallier tous les os et
leur donner du courage temps à nous
nous avons fait notre devoir
quand on nous disait que par le choix de
notre marche du 23 peut-être nous
marchions sur les plates bandes des
syndicats nous leur avons dit passer
devant
prenez la tête nous vous suivrons nous
aiderons appelé à une grande
manifestation qui aurait lieu sur les
champs elysées pour montrer par là même
l'endroit où nous voulons aller et en
même temps la quantité qu'il faut
rassembler que s'est il passé rien alors
comme je les dis paraît que je suis
dépressif mais non je vis très bien
la lucidité moi ne me rends pas
dépressif c'est le contraire et je pense
que c'est l'aveuglément devant la
réalité qui souvent peut conduire à
l'abattement
il faut appeler par leur nom les
problèmes qui se pose si on veut les
régler jeudi que la division entre le
mouvement social le mouvement associatif
et le mouvement politique que nous
incarnons nous condamne à la défaite et
que le rassemblement nous promet la
victoire
voilà ce que les prix et je lui dis pas
qu'on passe à côté de cette explication
pour un ventre et je ne sais quelques
râles de personnes volent des mois de
querelles de personnes j'ai pas le temps
voilà la bataille ces deux visions du
monde la france était la dernière ligne
de résistance du de l'europe celles qui
résistaient socialement et voilà qu'en
trois mois le code du travail a été
renversé et que la bataille était d'une
difficulté terrifiante parce que pendant
que nour expliquer aux gens ce qu'était
la hiérarchie des normes et le principe
de faveur ce n'est pas facile à faire
eh bien vous en avez d'autres qui
étaient pourtant censés être les chefs
de la lutte qui veut n'expliquait pas du
tout le problème ne se posait pas
ça a été très difficile comme bataille
il ne faut pas retourner à ses
conditions il faut sortir par le haut
c'est à dire par leur rassemblement
c'est à nous de le dire et il va falloir
que vous compreniez mes amis tout ce que
vous portiez ça regardez bien comme
cette situation et qualifiante
regardez bien l'ampleur des dégâts
qu'ont occasionnels et holland & company
ramener tout l'ancien courant
progressiste de gauche à 32% et
maintenant c'est nous
qui sommes la seule force politique à
plus de 10%
il faut assumer cette responsabilité
c'est à dire qu'il faut toujours parler
au grand nombre aux millions pas aux
milliers pas aux centaines par dizaines
par copa aux millions pour les entraîner
vers un autre chemin ce qui se prépare
c'est la france des riches pour les
riches contre tous les autres ce qui se
prépare c'est une misère de masse ce qui
se prépare c'est un abandon de tous les
services publics c'est ça qui se prépare
le dire ce n'est pas démoraliser c'est
regarder en face et appeler sans cesse à
la lutte en tâchant d'en réunir dans les
meilleures conditions possibles les
moyens et après advienne que pourra
comme dans nos vies nous faisons ce que
nous devons faire et puis advienne que
pourra
comme a pu le dire céline bushiens comme
a pu le dire
philippe chrisman comme ont pu le dire
tous ceux qui sont là tant de fois dans
leur existence
je fais ce qui est juste et advienne que
pourra je vais rien dire de vos travaux
[Applaudissements]
et les gens diraient rien parce que
c'est vous qui les menait pas moi j'ai
fait cette introduction avec le goût au
coeur d'être le passeur
on me dit qu est ce que vous êtes
moi ça me suffit
je ne suis pas le chef ces gens n'ont
pas besoin je suis le président du
groupe parlementaire la france insoumise
et je ne suis candidat à rien d'autre le
mouvement appartient à ceux qui veulent
le faire vivre
mais aussi à ceux qui ne font rien qui
nous aident d'un mot aimable d'une
attention de quelque argent donné d'un
coup de main dans l'action est
aujourd'hui demain vous allez par des
méthodes totalement déroutante et auquel
la plupart des gens n'y comprennent rien
inventé cette autre façon de faire
vous ne vous laisserez pas ramené aux
anciennes façons bon ça serait pas moi
qui conclut si je vous disais pas
quelques verres mais là cela m'ont posé
quelques problèmes
c'est un poème de victor hugo poème un
riche à n'importe lequel
ou bien à un copain des riches ou un
larbin des riches jeune homme
c'est victor hugo qui parle un jeune
homme mais qui parle
enfin bon
je nomme je te plains est cependant
j'admire ton grand parc enchantée qui
semble nous sourire j'admire ton domaine
et pourtant je te plains dans les
coteaux penchant au fumet un mot près
des lacs près des fleurs sous les larges
rameaux dans tes propres jardins
tu vas aussi stupide aussi peu
clairvoyant dont on à stains cupide
aussi sourd à la vie à l'harmonie aux
voix quand loup sauvage errant au milieu
des bois fanon cher victor nantes n'ont
que serviteur les loups ne tue que pour
manger il ne démord pas leurs semblables
ben bella
voilà pour ce discours de jean-luc
mélenchon qui a donc ouvert la
convention de la france insoumise qui se
tient ce week-end à clermont-ferrand
dans un discours de plus d'une heure et
ludovic on va avant de revenir sur le
fond de ce discours est ce qu a dit jean
luc mélenchon et bien on peut dire le
devis qu'on a retrouvé jean luc
mélenchon le tribun oui c'est un très
bon jean luc mélenchon avec toujours des
références des formules la forme est
intéressante aussi parce que tu es stand
up qui nous rappelle un peu la campagne
présidentielle et est ce que faisait
emmanuel macron à la différence qu
emmanuel macron avait souvent des
prompteurs alors que jean luc mélenchon
par le lui quasiment sans note même si
on voit bien qu'il jette un oeil de
temps en temps c'est un discours très
très construit malgré tout et puis la
forme sert toujours aussi le fond et ce
qui est frappant est toujours dans les
discours de jean-luc mélenchon
c'est ce côté un petit peu près
professeur alain lui se qualifie de
passeur et donc qui est toujours un
petit côté un peu éducation populaire en
fait dans ses discours qui ressemble
même parfois à une forme d du
d'édification des masses comme comme on
disait autrefois nicolas sur la forme de
ce discours on lisait un discours de
plus d'une heure quasiment sans notes
c'est l'art oratoire de jean-luc
mélenchon
oui bien sûr avec une géographie aussi
qu'il reste un peu la même que celle de
la présidentielle c'est à dire le
candidat au milieu de l'audience qui
s'adresse aux uns et aux autres en se
tournant qui n'est pas face et pas face
directement aux gens dont il est au
milieu des gens bon ça c'est une marque
de fabrique qui est qu'il a développé
pendant la campagne présidentielle et
qu'il reproduit ici donc on voit bien
qu'on est dans la forme dans la
continuité de son engagement
présidentiel
il n'y a pas eu dans le discours on y
viendra de rupture fondamentale avec
tous ses propos de campagne précédent on
comprend bien qu'il est dans une forme
d'entretien de continuité de son aura
auprès de ses troupes à la fois sur la
forme à la fois sur le fond c'est à dire
l'espace qu'il occupe à gauche le plus
possible et on y viendra sans doute avec
des tentatives d'énergie encore son
auditoire
ces prochains mois avant les élections
européennes stéphane rozès avant de
passer au fond du discours oui on
on a la chance de suivre apprécié dans
son intégralité c'est le pédagogue
piaget kids on prend un arbre on découpe
en tranches on met des tranchées une au
dessus des autres et puis un arbre est
bien ce que l'on fait nous souvent dans
nos commentaires politico médiatique
c'est qu'on découpe en tranches ce que
disent les orateurs les tribuns sait
plus véritablement ce qu'ils disent et
là on comprend au fond le fond de ce
qu'il ya en france deux orateurs qui au
travers de ce qu'ils disent nous font
comprendre qu'ils approchent
l'idée de la france de sa compréhension
et qu'ils savent lui parler c'est en ce
moment emmanuel macron et très
certainement jean luc mélenchon on ne se
rend pas compte comme à l'écouté il fait
penser ou discours autrefois par exemple
d'un jaurès
il commence en citant edmond rostand
corneille y termine par hugo c'est à
dire par note plus grands écrivains qui
tenait ensemble théâtre la poésie la
littérature le cinéma à venir il va au
génie français
toujours selon la même rhétorique il
commence par une situation sociale par
une lutte deuxième temps la dénonciation
troisième temps la france son histoire
l'intérêt général la république le monde
l'humanisme et il termine par la france
insoumise est au service de ce propos
vous le disait nicolas prissette un tout
au long de son discours finalement jean
luc mélenchon il a développé ce qui
était à ses thèmes de campagne
l'écologie l'europe la laïcité
il est resté sur ceux sur son fil
conducteur un fil conducteur qui l'a
maintenant depuis des mois oui alors
avec une dominante on va dire économique
et social des thématiques comme celle de
l'industrie qu'il a pu aborder pendant
ce discours
et puis on a entendu aussi un discours
qui s'adressait beaucoup à la gauche et
à des catégories de la gauche de
l'électorat
les fonctionnaires c'était une de ces
parties au début du discours et puis
après un gros passage long passage sur
l'écologie alors il ya eu le glyphosate
le climat etc tout y est passé
tout ce qui fait l'actualité de
l'écologie est passé donc on a entendu
un jean luc mélenchon qui
tout en étant dans la constance de sa
pensée et de son discours est bien a
aussi tenu à adresser des messages à
tous ses segments de l'électorat de
gauche qui peuvent avoir voté pour lui
au premier tour de la présidentielle
mais qui peuvent aussi pour d'autres
être aujourd'hui en déshérence faute de
leadership du parti socialiste bien sûr
d'autres composantes de la gauche les
écologistes et l'a dit lui même dans son
discours eh bien ça ne représente plus
une force politique aujourd'hui et donc
à travers tous ces différents messages
on voit bien qu'ils essayent de tenir le
spectre globale qui a aujourd'hui entre
enfin à la gauche des manuels macron et
dont il est finalement le seul porte
voix actuellement on va tout de suite
prendre la direction de clermont ferrand
où se tenait à ce discours de jean-luc
mélenchon pour une première réaction
politique sale d'infidèles de jean luc
mélenchon le député la france insoumise
de seine-saint-denis alexis corbière
alors dès le début de son discours
discours jean luc mélenchon a parlé de
mouvement et pas de parti qu'il n'y
avait pas de police de la pensée au sein
du mouvement qu'est ce que cela signifie
alexis corbière sait combien de jours
vous allez avoir beaucoup de travaux de
la part de tous les gens qui sont là et
que c'est l'aboutissement au sud du mans
une étape d'un long processus qui s'est
engagé depuis des mois ce qu'on souhaite
c'est que ce soit d'abord tournée vers
l'action plutôt que figé des choses dans
des structures est bel et bien sur la
base de campagne certaines ont été
montrées là notamment le fait que une
opinion campagne pour la sortie du
nucléaire pendant que tu es un grand
sujet aujourd'hui la transition
écologique
c'est ça qui est important c'est que le
caractère dynamique utile pour le peuple
de ce mouvement soit confirmée par des
choses concrètes
ça peut être des actions de solidarité
ici ou là ça peut être selon les villes
des quartiers et c'est ça que nous
cherchons à faire quelque chose de flou
dans lequel on peut finir sur une
campagne peut-être être moins présent
après apporter son aide d'une manière
qui est la plus modeste ou la plus
impliquée
nous ce qui nous importe je crois que
c'est le maître mot de ce qu'a dit jean
luc mélenchon c'est que nous ne perdons
pas de vue que durant les élections un
électeur sur deux n'est pas allé voter
le problème n'est pas de discuter avec
des militants mais comment nous allons
au contact de ce grand peuple français
qui est un peuple très politique mais
qui moitié a perdu parfois bout à
l'action civique parce que notamment le
savez notre critique des institutions
mettent un peu le citoyen à distance on
vote pour des gens ils respectent pas
leur parole pape on n'a plus de pouvoir
donc il faut aller
chercher ces abstentionnistes dans les
quartiers populaires est allé les
chercher sur des choses dans lequel ils
se sentent à leur place sans qu'on leur
demande d'adhérer à un parti qui parfois
vous le savez à ses lourdeurs ses codes
ses codes de vocabulaire ses codes de
fonction nous c'est autre chose c'est
original
on tâtonne un on est un peu dans du mais
on voit bien qu'il ya quelque chose de
très dynamique on a cinq cent quarante
mille personnes aujourd'hui qui se
regroupent et qui agissent sur notre
plateforme
est-ce que stratégiquement il ne
faudrait pas fédéré autour des autres
forces de gauche pour être plus visible
plus efficace
bah c'est ça le débat moi je ne pense
pas que ça veut pas dire qu'il faut de
dire travailler à la division c'est même
l'inversé vous avez entendu jean luc
mélenchon dans la riposte dans la
résistance face aux coûts de main d
manueel macro nous n'avons pas de
problème à travailler avec d'autres
forces politiques mais l'enjeu comme
nous le disons c'est pas tellement de
rassembler la gauche c'est à dire passer
du temps dans des diplomaties de petits
partis qui peuvent parfois être assez
bon monde si je puis dire mais comment
on fédère le peuple dira comment
rassemble toute une série de gens que je
viens de nommer ceux qui sont les plus
éloignés parfois du débat politique
c'est ça qui est important
parler au plus grand nombre à l'aller au
delà on a un ensemble de sept millions
d'électeurs mais parler à ses 44
millions d'électeurs que nous avons en
france qui je le répète d'un seul on
trouve que il suffit pas de se réclamer
de la gauche mais je ne sais trop quoi
pour qu'ils comprennent ce que nous
voulons dire bon ça ça se fait dans
mille et une petites luttes du quotidien
d'actions concrètes du quotidien dans
lequel je le répète c'est cette fluidité
du mouvement qui peut selon nous permet
de faire adhérer les gens plutôt que des
fois ses états majors de partis qui se
réunissent et qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus
de capacité propulsif comme il avait
avant on n'est plus dans les années 70
ou 80 où il se fit dire les grands chefs
de partis sont mis d'accord et dans ce
coup les gens sont tirés et se
mobiliseraient sauter une pédagogie vous
savez quoi notre combat est d'abord
culturel
il est idéologique qui pour reforger un
goût du futur en idéal est une société
vers laquelle nous on on pourrait
avancer
il ya des choses très partagée dans la
société aujourd'hui la prise de
conscience de la crise écologique des
injustices sociales mais il faut mettre
en mouvement pour ça donc à la fin de
ces deux jours jean luc mélenchon ne
sera toujours pas le chef de la france
au nom ne vous en déplaise des normes il
a été le candidat
évidemment il a une place particulière
il est un émetteur plus fort que
d'autres mais il faut que ça reste
fluide mobile voyez à des échéances
électorales qui viennent jean luc
mélenchon a avancé l'idée pense que ça
aura des listes europe insoumise donc il
y aura d'autres candidats d'autres
visages et mélenchon est une des pièces
je dirais pas secondaire évidemment mais
de cette mécanique que nous allons
mettre à neuf
c'est une locomotive qui entraîne et
puis moi avec mes amis députés
on va pas être démagogique on est bien
conscient que les parlementaires antho
rôle particulier mais il faut savoir à
la fois entraîné et en même temps savoir
s'effacer devant aussi toute cette
dynamique est là ces femmes ces hommes
bons et jean luc a ouvert les travaux
mais il faut maintenant que ce mouvement
continue d'exister que son propre rythme
merci elle et syco bien d'avoir répondu
à nos questions en direct sur les
chaînes parlementaires
merci beaucoup nathalie et à tout à
l'heure pour d'autres réactions
politiques à votre micro alors on
entendait à l'accent alexis corbière
parler de cette critique qui est faite
cette personnalisation du parti jean luc
mélenchon eh bien il ya répondu au début
de son discours on écoute j'ai noté que
ceux là même qui me traitait de
dictateurs naguère dorénavant me demande
d'exercer je ne sais quelle police
politique de la pente est dans le groupe
parlementaire est ailleurs il n'y en
aura pas
la force de la france insoumis c'est
qu'elle est un mouvement
elle n'est pas un parti et n'a donc pas
besoin d'une homogénéité des pensées
elle a besoin d'une homogénéité de
l'action et c'est pourquoi elle est
toute entière tournée vers l'action
ludovic à cette question de la
personnalisation du parti c'est une
question récurrente à la france
insoumise
jean luc mélenchon lui l'a dit nous ne
sommes pas un parti nous ça nous sommes
un mouvement je ne suis pas le chef
oui alors sauf que sauf que dans la
réalité des faits c'est pas vrai c'est à
dire que et stéphane décrivait très bien
tout à l'heure à la france insoumise
comme à la république en marche
il ya à la fois une très grande
horizontalité à la base et des choses
qui remonte vers le haut mais il ya
aussi une très grande verticalité et ses
deux parties on sait le mouvement auront
choisi de résoudre ça de façon
différente c'est à dire qu'à la
république en marche
il ya une désignation élections qui se
fait à main levée
et à la france insoumise bas il n'ya pas
d'élection du tout comme ça c'est encore
plus facile et personne n'ose n'osera
contesté à jean luc mélenchon le fait
qu'il a le leadership naturel sur sur ce
mouvement est donc voilà il en est pas
le chef peut-être dans par une élection
mais il en est le chef
dans les faits ne pas vouloir être le
chef finalement c'est le meilleur moyen
de l'être pour jean luc mélenchon à
stéphane rozès c'est d'évidence et jean
luc mélenchon le chef il ya un peu
malignité de sa part parce qu'il nous
fait comme si il nous fait le coup du
démocrate non c'est pas le sujet c'est
qu'il a compris que comme il s'était
trompé d'analystes sur l'après
présidentielle
il fallait maintenant gérer ce quatre
ans et qu'ils ne pouvaient pas être en
première ligne et qu'il devait laisser
sa formation travailler sur des
thématiques qu'espérer que des actions
comme il le dit c'est très intéressant
ils semblent dire les idées dit biz
c'est l'action qui nous rassemble parce
qu'on est tenu par le bas par le peuple
et donc il gère maintenant le temps il a
compris qu'il devait gérer le temps en
se mettant à l'écart en laissant sa
formation travailler et il reviendra
ensuite quand le temps de la verticalité
politique reviendra pour apparaître
comme étant à la fois l'alternance et de
son point de vue l'alternative nicolas
prissette on a parlé à au début de cette
émission des polémiques qui ont lieu
concernant un des membres de la france
insoumise et notamment des propos de
danièle obono est ce que quand jean luc
mélenchon dans l'extrait convient
d'entendre parle de la police de la
pensée c'est une manière de revenir sur
ces polémiques où il ya un directement
parce que s'agissant de danièle obono
bon il ya le sujet qui a été abordé
c'était quand même un sujet de fond on
est quand même dans une polémique qui
traite de racisme ou d'antisémitisme
donc là forcément bien on se retourne
vers le chef on le demande mais est-ce
que vous cautionnez ou pas l'attitude de
danièle obono pour le reste des autres
polémiques qui ont lieu il y en a eu
c'est jean luc mélenchon lui-même qu'il
a suscité vous savez avec sa fameuse
phrase sur les nazis
là il y a répondu aussi dans son
discours il a tenu à remettre les points
sur les i et est lui-même
endosser la responsabilité bien sûr de
la phrase et puis le 2 à nouveau
dégonfler la polémique qui était né à ce
moment là sinon pour le reste des autres
sujets de friction ça a été des sujets
on va dire plus personnel avec des
petites affaires qui peuvent concerner
tel ou tel membre de la france on mise
donc pour ces cas-là pense par exemple
aux habitations hlm de danielle simonnet
ou enfin qui n'est pas un chalet mme
pardon mais qui est à des régies de la
ville de paris ou de alexis corbière
voilà c'est des affaires plus
personnelles c'est normal que jean luc
mélenchon ne se soit pas mise en avant
dans ces cas là c'est juste un mot pour
en finir peut-être sur le chef ce qui
est intéressant de noter c'est que jean
luc mélenchon a pris la seule finalement
position institutionnelle dont pouvaient
bénéficier la france insoumise
c'est la fonction de président de groupe
à l'assemblée nationale n'y a pas eu de
débat au sein de la france un sou lice
pour savoir qui prenait cette
responsabilité il a été le seul candidat
et il a été élu par les députés de la
france insoumise et donc on voit bien
que c'est finalement la meilleure preuve
qu'il ya bien un chef à la france
insoumis c'est jean luc mélenchon est
d'une certaine façon ils l'assument ici
à l'assemblée avec ce que ça comporte en
termes c'est important pour participer à
la vie de l'assemblée nationale cette
fonction de président de groupe et ça il
assume tout à fait en plus de la
personnalisation du parti et l'autre
question qui se pose c'est celle de la
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon cible
de critiques est bien là aussi il y a
répondu renvoyant la balle à deux de ses
adversaires emmanuel macron et manuel
valls somme le mouvement de
l'argumentation pas de la vitupération
ni de la victime
comme il est loin ce temps où l'on
disait de moi parce que je prétendais
par les crues et dru que je serai
excessif et agressif depuis vous avez
été régaler de sinik rien feignant
petits enfants qui attendaient le père
noël etc et cetera et cetera
je ne décide pas évidemment l'ignoble
monsieur valls et ses aboiements
permanent et fans rozès il a été
beaucoup reproché à jean luc mélenchon a
d'être excessif agressif et bien à lui
il dit en citant notamment des propos de
emmanuel macron finalement le plus
agressif ce n'est peut-être pas moi
oui effectivement il ya eu beaucoup de
critiques dans le passé on a même dit
que jean luc mélenchon serait impropre
populiste donc il a été attaqué sur sa
personne durant la campagne
et là il dit mais non nous nous sommes
la formation et le courant de pensée de
la concorde de la raison je crois même
de la paix civile at il dit à un moment
ce sont des autres qui sont des fauteurs
de troubles par leur politique par leurs
mots d'abord alors qu'en is it manuel
valls il revient lui-même dans
l'invectivant dit en ignoble manuel
valls bon donc
ce qui est vrai c'est que durant ce
discours il n'a éludé aucun des éléments
critiques
il a voulu donner une réponse y compris
contre des rumeurs qui serait dépressif
dont il a tout un moment sur dépressif
enfin des pressions et lucidité il faut
lui reconnaître qu'il a tout et je
voudrais revenir quand même là où encore
il esquive quand même quelque chose sur
l'échec de la rentrée sociale c'est
qu'il met ça sur le compte de la
division syndicale mais ça fait des
lustres qu'elle existe et bizarrement il
remet en cause l'achat
damien alors plus de même autrefois dans
le passé l'a tellement défendu donc
c'est bien une question selon moi
d'abord politique qu'a été sa mauvaise
appréciation des choses et non pas
quelque chose venant du paysage syndical
qui est ce qu'il est au fond depuis des
décennies de bécasses mais ce n'est
qu'une question politique avec ce qu'il
ya aussi un problème avec la
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon dans
un sondage aux hawks à paris hier 69%
des sondés trouvent sur luc mélenchon
très progressif
oui trop agressif trop qui agit de façon
trop personnelle aussi à soit 68% donc
on voit bien qu effectivement sa
personnalité pose question il faut se
rappeler qu'à une époque jean luc
mélenchon s'était défini comme le bruit
et la fureur
alors au delà de la formule ça n'avait
pas très bien fonctionné dans les faits
et ce qui avait semblé fonctionner
pendant toute la première partie de la
dernière campagne présidentielle c'est
au contraire un jean luc mélenchon plus
plus apaisée plus et on a vu que quand
le débat s'est durci au cours de la
présente campagne présidentielle il est
revenu à un ton effectivement plus
offensive voire agressif et
pas forcément servi on va retourner en
direct de clermont ferrand retrouvez
nathalie guizouarn à tallinn autres
réactions politiques à votre micro celle
de clémentine autain la députée la
france insoumise de seine-saint-denis
alors jean-luc mélenchon pendant son
discours a évoqué la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
emmanuel macron aussi ce matin est ce
que vous êtes satisfaite des
propositions faite ce matin par emmanuel
marc écoutez je trouve important que le
président l'a après même président de la
république prenne la mesure du mouvement
extraordinaire qui s'est produit dans
notre pays et pas seulement même à
travers le monde pour libérer la parole
contre les violences faites aux femmes
et de telle sorte qu'elles puissent
sortir du tableau mais maintenant ce
qu'on attend d'un gouvernement du
président de la république c'est qu'il
dégage les moyens financiers humains qui
permettent d'accompagner la parole de
ces femmes pour faire en sorte que
justice puisse être rendue et que tous
les mécanismes qui aboutissent à ces
phénomènes de violence ultime ou de
harcèlement d'agression qui ont à voir
avec les stéréotypes sexistes avec cette
société qui est empreinte de domination
masculine et bien nous avons besoin de
former et policiers de faire en sorte
que les justiciers les moyens de traiter
les sujets que le mouvement associatif
et des moyens lui aussi de faire son
travail
et tout cela ne peut pas rentrer dans
les clous de l'austérité de ce
gouvernement est d'ailleurs le président
de la république n'a rien annoncé de
sonnants et trébuchants
pour faire face à cette situation il a
annoncé une augmentation de 420 millions
du budget c'est suffisant c'est une
plaisanterie
pardonnez moi de vous le dire c'est
vraiment
décevant triste et en même temps c'est
la preuve s'il en fallait que ce
gouvernement ne raisonne que dans le cas
de la règle d'or même pour ces violences
faites aux femmes qui mériterait une
grande cause nationale une grande cause
nationale c'est pas ce chiffre dérisoire
qui met en réalité le budget les droits
des femmes quasiment à égalité par
rapport à l'année précédente
alors on va déshabiller peut-être un peu
les moyens les subsides qu'ils étaient
aujourd'hui pour l'égalité
professionnelle ou même pour les moyens
d'accompagnement sur le phénomène
prostitutionnel on va les prendre pour
faire la caravane et quelques petits
éléments nouveaux pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes
honnêtement je vous le dis sincèrement
ce n'est absolument pas la hauteur de ce
que la société a porté ces dernières
semaines dans le débat public
merci clémentine autain lave a répondu à
nos questions en direct sur les chaînes
parlementaires
merci beaucoup et nathalie pour cette
réaction directe de clermont ferrand ce
sujet des violences faites aux femmes
c'était le sujet du jour notamment pour
le président de la république qui a
prononcé un discours sur ce sujet dans
la matinée jean luc mélenchon lui aussi
il y est revenu pendant son discours en
écoute quand nous sommes dans
l'assemblée nationale ou sur le terrain
évidemment à l'assemblée nationale nous
sommes la main dans la main avec les
députés communistes sur le terrain avec
des militants de toute étiquette mais si
nous regardons la scène institutionnels
qu'est ce qu'on me demande à la fin
dois-je et pourtant nous avons fait des
gestes nous avons dit nous sommes prêt
s'il le faut à parler même avec les
socialistes à condition qu'ils se disent
d'opposition mais voilà qu'ils votent
sur la confiance 5 votre la confiance 3
votre contrat avec nous et tout le reste
tiens qu'est-ce qu'une opposition qui
s'abstient à propos du gouvernement
auquel il s'oppose
voilà pour cet extrait qu'il n'était pas
un extrait sur les violences faites aux
femmes mais ce qui va nous permettre de
parler à moins que ses fans voulaient
peut-être dire un petit mot de ce sujet
en cuisine on sait tout de cet extrait
tout à fait révélateur de la philosophie
parce que nous commentateurs
journalistes on a toujours à 10 danses à
dire mais alors comment ils font entre
direction
c'est pas du tout la philosophie de
jean-luc mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon dit que les
dynamiques politiques ne sont pas des
agrégations d'appareils horizontaux et
je crois que de ce point de vue là il a
tout à fait raison de la constater
durant la présidentielle que c'est le
bas qui fait le haut et pas la carte des
appareils politiques qui fait de la
dynamique politique et de ce point de
vue là il reste dans sa constante donc
il est content de pouvoir voir qui peut
faire des choses avec les uns et les
autres mais ils se font du lot
non évidemment faso sans problème au
numéro et à fait vrai c'est qu'il n'a
pas grand monde avec qui discuter et il
le reconnaît lui-même il l'a dit dans
une interview au parisien cette semaine
que la direction du parti communiste
n'est pas très tenté de discuter avec
lui que les verts n'existe quasiment
plus que le parti socialiste on viens de
l'entendre on sait pas trop si ici les
dents dans l'opposition pas donc de ce
point de vue là il fait aussi un peu
contre mauvaise fortune bon coeur
puisqu'il ya pas il n'y a pas grand
monde avec qui discuter et bien et bien
c'est pas grave faisons en faisant
autrement et on sent bien effectivement
c'est cette volonté de court circuiter
en fait les appareils pour en appeler
directement à la base directement au
peuple parce qu'il pressent bien sans
doute un jean luc mélenchon aussi que de
la part des appareils qui tente de
survivre au parti communiste comme au
parti socialiste il ya une petite
tentation peut être d'une sorte de tout
sauf mélenchon on verra comment ça se
passe pour les élections européennes
mais voilà jean luc mélenchon qui a fait
un très beau score à l'élection
présidentielle il a besoin maintenant de
d'ancrer sa dent dans la durée et la
discussion d'appareils malgré tout il ya
le nouveau monde et puis l ancien monde
mais ça compte encore les discussions
d'appareils quand il faut conclure des
accords électoraux pour des élections
nicolas nicolas prissette un rique par
là à l'instant de ce tout sauf mélenchon
est ce que ce n'est pas un risque ça
pour jean luc mélenchon qu'il y ait une
à lens entre benoît hamon le parti
communiste
europe ecologie les verts contre lui
bien sûr c'est son risque majeur pour
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
c'est que quelqu'un à gauche d'autres
que lui définit ce qu'est la gauche
entre emmanuel macron et jean luc
mélenchon est la personne qui définira
cette nouvelle gauche entre les deux si
tenté que cela soit possible
attention seulement prudent occupera
immédiatement un espace au détriment de
jean luc mélenchon
donc il au cdh en est parfaitement
conscient et c'est pour ça qui s'est
autoproclamé même si les sondages sont
peu on l'a dit soeur favorable dans ce
sens meilleur opposant à emmanuel macron
il a dit cette phrase tout à l'heure il
ya deux visions du monde qui
s'affrontent donc à la sienne et il ya
celles de macron il est vraiment s'est
placé dans un antagonisme assez radical
donc d'un côté comme ils le répètent les
puissants les capitalistes etc et de
l'autre côté bien lui le mouvement qu'il
représenta france insoumise il n'a pas
beaucoup parlé de ses adversaires en
réalité n'a pas beaucoup nommer ses
adversaires pendant ce discours il ya
trois noms qui sont venus celui de
maquereaux évidemment celui de hollande
vers la fin et puis valls on l'a entendu
dans dans l'extrait tout à l'heure mais
il ne parle pas du tout du reste de
l'échiquier politique on l'a pas entendu
parler de la droite de laurent wauquiez
par exemple qui est un adversaire
naturel pour jean luc mélenchon
pas un mot rien du tout et puis on n'a
pas dans tous exactement entendu parler
de marine le pen
alors là l'extrême droite dans son
discours ça n'existe pas le populisme de
droite ça n'existe pas et c'est vrai que
en occultant complètement cette réalité
politique là eh bien il semble vouloir
apparaître comme étant le seul capable
de s'opposer à macron ludovic nicolas
parle à l'instant de ces deux visions du
monde qu'a voulu
décrire jean luc mélenchon est ce que ce
n'est pas aussi de vision de l'europe
qui l'a voulu à décrire durant son
discours parce que pour la france ont
misé bien la prochaine la prochaine et
sciences ce sont les européennes et il
veut peut-être faire de ces européennes
un référendum pro anti macron un
référendum pro anti européen et donc
s'opposer à la vision de l'europe
d'emmanuel macron oui bah on voit
d'ailleurs de ce point de vue là qu il
ya une forme de d'alliance objective
peut être un même on pourrait dire entre
entre le président de la république et
jean luc mélenchon leur entretien cette
semaine à l'elysée sur les européennes
d'ailleurs c'est assez bien assez bien
passé un jean luc mélenchon en sortant a
expliqué emmanuel macron avait des
défauts mais comment il avait une
qualité c'est qu'il ne fuyait pas le
débat et ce débat effectivement il
existe entre eux sur sur la conception
de l'europe et on voit bien qu
effectivement c'est aussi une façon pour
l'un et pour l'autre d'effacer en
quelque sorte un la concurrence du parti
socialiste d'un côté des républicains de
l'autre et il faut se rappeler que
pendant déjà le débat d'avant premier
tour de l'élection présidentielle on
avait senti sur le plateau de télévision
une certaine complicité entre emmanuel
macron et jean luc mélenchon il tient
des très rapidement sur la souveraineté
parce que l'un et l'autre disent nous
sommes des patriotes
vive la souveraineté de la nation battre
on dit oui mais vivent souveraineté
européenne et mélenchon dit non pas 9 à
10 européennes parce qu'elle vient pas
un peuple européen merci stéphane rozès
merci à tous les trois d'avoir été sur
ce plateau pour analyser ce discours de
jean-luc mélenchon
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi et à
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]